two hello everybody Happy Thanksgiving
Eve that's tomorrow November today is
November 23rd it's a Wednesday and uh
just so happy to be here with my family
and uh my family here who I love so well
Zach unfortunate is Cam here today
cam is here oh welcome back he's back
from the tortoise the torta uh no
can I ask you Kim did you eat that whole
torta that you showed us I had a uh like
half of what was left yesterday uh two
days ago and what did you stop because
you were full or did you start to feel
ill already it tasted off oh no
uh but the first half was amazing and I
would definitely eat it again
so what went wrong in the second half it
just didn't taste like good meat and uh
as it turns out it wasn't I was telling
Ian uh when I threw it out too it was
like this uh wasn't as good the second
time around you can say that again yeah
yeah and there's some if there should
that much meat on a sandwich if it
doesn't cost 50 you should be concerned
it had like every greasy red meat you
can imagine on it too there was a hot
dog in there there was oh my goodness
wow yeah well welcome back uh Zach
unfortunately was completely taken out
by the Gabe curse we don't actually know
do we know what's wrong with him uh
specifically like what kind of illness
is he experiencing a cough I know cough
he said it's blue like has he been
tested has he did he test he said he
went to the doctor oh for covet yeah he
said no Covenant just regular old flu
if you believe that he's really sorry I
I don't want to put that out there too
much he's sick he's sick you know what I
mean people start to
people start to take it seriously and
then they go speak you know people
people take like he's having a little
Ferris Bueller's Day Off right now
do you think so he's he's cruising
around you tried to drag Cam Cameron
it's like the movie cam was with him
that's right
we saw actually unlike um
Cameron at least I haven't seen a
picture of Zach at that airport
oh come on I'm just kidding yeah I
panicked when you sent that message I
know I know you're saying it was funny
though it was funny there was a picture
that came up
a fan uh took a photo with Cam at
designer calm which was last weekend but
I swear to God it looked just like you
were at an airport
that's the Anaheim Convention Center
hold on I'm pulling up and we're like oh
Cam's sick huh because the title was I
just took a picture with Cam you know
what I mean no no it wasn't that hold on
yes it was it was like I literally just
saw a camera in two seconds ago it was I
just met cam I was like oh really Kim my
heart started racing me drop that in the
chat I was like no it's not no it's
designer con no you can tell you have
the badge on and everything but it says
I just met cam
I
literally just shook hands with Cameron
on today November 23rd at 1 00 p.m
that's how I read it that's how I said
exactly what I read yeah at the airport
at the airport he's on his way to Cancun
no I'm glad you're here though Kim uh
your presence is missed his so is Zach
so I'm sorry to have missed the uh you
left you lose yesterday was it a good
was it good actually it was a it was a
very fun show it was very good we um
maybe the best one yet depends who you
ask
well right well no spoilers to baby and
no spoilers baby baby baby baby
hey baby hey baby a b made out the best
of anybody and he's here complaining
it's like come on bro I can't wait to
watch it you'll have to watch it to find
out yeah so anyway we we pre-recorded
yesterday our traditional UF you lose
which is going up on Friday it was great
it was fun I actually brought the Heat
this year I'm feeling pretty proud of
myself you you get the most improved uh
award for sure
yes no actually my my favorite video of
the whole thing was was the one I made
nice I'm glad yeah I got you I rewatched
it because I edited the episode together
this morning and it had me [ __ ] okay
good good good good when after I had
spent a little bit editing it I was I
was cracking up when I was editing it
but then afterwards I was like
is this funny at all or just weird yeah
that's funny yeah yeah yeah
well that that's what happens when you
stare at a video for too long yeah
well there that is
um there it is so welcome everybody yeah
but you know
with Thanksgiving on the horizon I do
want to just say
what I am grateful for here uh um I am
so grateful
for all the audience members
all the the lovely Community we have
here who you know
it's nice because there's a lot of
[ __ ] people that hate me on the
internet you know for one reason or
another
some for real reasons some for not
you know
but regardless you all got my back and
that that feels good man to have like uh
people that believe in you and know what
you're about so that that that's great
you know I love our the community we've
built here
and uh love you all guys so much all you
betas and soys out there
beta Nation baby
someone said oh somebody donated to say
hold on
where'd that go somebody Bree run
somebody donated two dollars to say why
you clickbait crit kind of cringe bro
okay well you don't even know what I'm
talking about so
yeah it's clickbait a little bit I mean
I'm talking about his little his homie
uh Kaya and um why can't I clickbait uh
crit wait someone paid two dollars to
say your cringe yeah interesting
I find that interesting is that
that is interesting actually uh I
appreciate that I mean I'll take two
bucks why not after the cut thirty
percent I mean I'll get like 70 cents
and I'm down with that yeah
um I think you're kind of cringe bro why
you like
care that much he's just a [ __ ]
YouTuber bro you know what I mean
I'd pull up the uh picture of Charlie
riding a dick and show it to you if it
wasn't way too lewd to show on YouTube
oh that was yeah that's perfect although
it's a little ironic for me but like
he's just a YouTuber right thank
everyone for being like loyal foot
soldiers right he's just a YouTuber I'm
much more than that so
I'm realer
way more down to earth
and I've got I don't even have a foyer
at my house I'll have you all know
oh that's cringe though
no foyer no 48. also thank you the main
Broski five gifted Subs appreciate you
yeah I wanted to say thank you guys to
all you guys I love you all so much and
uh
it makes me happy to come to work man
I'll tell you this for sure
um yeah thank you Yuri said it's a
YouTube thumbnail anything goes thank
you somebody who understands me oh yeah
I would listen we have a great segment
about crit okay so don't don't lose your
[ __ ] [ __ ] okay until you watch it
thank you
um
yeah
being poor is cringe that's true stop
being poor
obviously I just love that it's like
you're obviously not a fan bro we
clickbait like as part of my personality
trait at this point
uh was I was saying
yeah I'm happy to come to work you know
that's like such a departure for me
where
um I actually look forward to doing the
show and I wake up and I look forward to
coming here and seeing the crew and
interacting with you guys and doing the
live show it's really
um a joy for me and uh
my career on YouTube has never been like
that basically
basically I would say since Frenemies
ended we really tightened no no nothing
to do with that that show is great I
love that show
what the [ __ ] yeah I'm sorry Tricia but
no I love I love I love that show
there's definitely no hate
but um
ever since that show we kind of buckled
down and we started doing like the four
days a week now five days with the
members podcast which is something that
I've always dreamed of doing but what I
never dreamed I would be able to do is
to do this show so uh
you know you you guys here make it easy
for me
if we didn't have this talented
hard-working passionate uh crew who
cares so much about this show I would
not be able to do what we do here every
week for
live streams a pub big shows a week and
so that's just not possible and I enjoy
it I enjoy coming here because he all
work so hard to make this show good
wouldn't be possible
it's so much work you know but but it's
good it's good I'm just so happy
yeah I was and uh
you know I really like my job right now
I don't know what to say but it's never
been like that for me it's always been
kind of like pulling teeth a pain in the
ass ambivalent feelings I don't have any
ambivalent feelings about this podcast
it's all good I'm Gonna Come
okay Dan stop I'm trying to be serious
you're just you're building this up so
much
oh that's true okay you can come
go ahead and finish I'll wait
no but uh yeah
that's what happens when you lose your
when I finish
oh God imagine that's the sound it makes
that's what it's like to be kaya from uh
moist criticals podcast
yeah oh thank you to okay thank you too
thank you for the gifted can the crew
say a late happy birthday for my cousin
Selena alrighty Selena Selena
Happy Birthday Selena wait happy
birthday yeah so I on this Thanksgiving
if you guys and you guys I'm very
thankful for because um
this is it man you know what I mean
we've I've arrived I feel like this this
is my spot where I'm supposed to be
and uh just love you all guys so much so
thank you everybody for making it
possible and I feel we really share
something special here together you know
so there it is
top podcast in the world number 12 at
least at one point recently
number one in California number one in
California should we talk about that
it's a good segue and Kentucky back in
Kentucky how can it be how can that be
real Kentucky in Virginia I think it's
just we got fans in Kentucky I think
it's the search history in each state so
here is the oh so maybe that's where all
the haters live yeah
I can't imagine there's a bunch of
kentuckans riding for the no I bet there
is I mean come out kentuckans kentuckans
out there also I'm sure like young
liberal people living in these places
probably seek Solace and channels like
this so who is gay that you think so
yeah that's true the kentuckans are
they're very conservative I mean that's
as conservatives you get boy doesn't
that make you good so most searched
podcasts by state and this is so cool
guys
um we actually are on the chart my
goodness H3 We the Kings the Cali baby
and I love that I love California I'm
Californian forever yeah and number one
in Michigan number one in Michigan we
love thank you that was all baby that
was me yeah I went door to door like uh
it's all 80s family trying to figure out
what he does for a living I don't know
can you say that I went the door to door
like a Jehovah Witness that's what I was
gonna say yeah you could say that why
can't you say that nobody cares about
Jehovah no we can offend him
well I spread the good word
no Jehovah's Witness don't watch this
show I can tell you that I mean they
might I don't know there's nothing
they're so devout bro they don't [ __ ]
around with any nonsense dude yeah
perhaps shout out to the Jehovah's shout
out of those who would if you're out
there shout out yeah some of the nicest
ladies ever at least going to my aunt's
house and my mom and my aunt used to try
to convince them that Islam was the way
reverse the Virgin surprised
[ __ ] oh that's funny
she probably didn't get much space on
that one did you no but they kept coming
they kept coming we used to mess with my
aunt because you're super religious so
we used to always like kick open the
door and say some wild [ __ ] and we
didn't know the Jehovah Witness ladies
were there and my cousin kicks open the
door he's like eight years old he's like
we're about to smoke some [ __ ] weed
up [ __ ] and they were looking at us
like what the [ __ ] they're like you do
need a God
yeah but we're we're crushing it man on
this chart we got
Colorado
Cali Cali Michigan
this is this Con this is Virginia
Virginia for the lovers
Kentucky and Missouri
uh let me I pulled up a map because I
didn't want yes that is Missouri
Missouri's fighting for H3 those plane
States
confuse the [ __ ] out of me it's really
hard
okay okay I'll take it Anna just sent a
Super Chat that said I live in Kentucky
thank God I'm moving to Chicago next
month Olivia is right so they must
we must be their liberal friend yeah
it's hard out there if you're a young
kind of woke more woke on the side
Kentucky's got to be hell for you for
real we got a lot of Jehovah Witnesses
in the chat oh we got a shout out to the
witnesses that's what I was saying I
don't think there's anything
about that faith that would prevent okay
so I'm ignorant on the witnesses but hey
one God one Jehovah whoever is Jehovah I
don't know the [ __ ] that is you know
what I mean
I'm sure they'll let you know in the
comments who the [ __ ] is Jehovah and
what the [ __ ] did he Witness
you're gonna get a knock on your door to
give you we got explanations Oddball
Paul thank you for the five gifted I'm
looking at the list of uh viewership by
state and um Cali number one for sure
but California is number one Texas
number is number two the New York
Florida in Illinois which those are all
predictable because those are all huge
dates but uh I do see Missouri's pretty
high up there and I think you know
they're punching above their weight when
it comes to population per capita I
think so yeah I love y'all missourians I
gotta be doing me a show out there boy
amen I gotta have me a live sermon amen
come on now we I'm gonna call it Ethan's
witness he witnessed me boy oh we
I'm looking pretty I need Jehovah
witnesses that watch the show they won't
anymore by the end of this episode no
come on they know they know what it's
like that's what I'm saying they're
witnessing my greatness every day dude
they love it oh boy I believe it
uh Missouri anyway um thank you to
everybody but that's pretty cool that um
whatever chart this is this website
it is
tied podcast pre-ply I don't know wait
we're tied in Utah
yo Dateline NBC I like wine
but Dateline I'm gonna have to do like
one of your storage and put you down
[ __ ]
can we game the system right now and
tell everyone at home to Google h35 yes
everybody at home wait no no Google does
Ryan coming to look like Harvey wants
you I don't want to waste those Google
search that's way more important true
true if you're Googling anything let it
be that
um and that is Ryan Cavanaugh is a force
of nature
Bree just got laid off I'm sorry to hear
that you'll get a new job soon it's a
great market for
for employ you got laid off you can be
finding a ninja job soon it's easily
right easily easily I don't know what
you do or what your situation is but
you're easily it's true I mean the
market is insane
employment rate is is quite good it
favors you so I don't know where these
idiots get off letting you go you let
them go [ __ ]
maybe she works for Twitter
um shout out for me please for my
birthday happy birthday Jenny appreciate
you 27. Jenny her birthday's on
Thanksgiving what do we think about that
that's kind of birthdays tomorrow yeah
well Thanksgiving changes each year
right because it's always on a Thursday
oh okay okay yeah it's not a specific
but that definitely is an overshadower
like I had a I had a friend whose
birthday was on New Year's Day it's like
that's rough you know that's rough
because who wants to come party on your
birthday very everybody's hung over
everybody yeah yeah
there it is
so anyway it's my mom's birthday she's
born does she like having that birthday
on that day or no I think so I don't
know yeah I don't think you care about
your birthday when you get older that's
true that is true once you're like
27 birthdays are over you know who it
doesn't matter for though if uh you're a
Jehovah's Witness yeah they don't true
they don't witness birthdays we're
holding you or holidays at all they
don't believe in celebrating I remember
that I had a friend in Middle School his
family was Jehovah's Witness and
I think I like got him like a pack of
Pokemon cards or something for his
birthday and he refused it and I was
very
put off by that at the time not like
insulted but I was just like it's
inconceivable yeah like to an 11 year
old that was like blowing my mind to a
37 year old it's inconceivable no stop
why how did you read my mind Ian oh my
God today is it today it's today's the
day hell yes all right guys it's getting
old it's not that funny anymore okay
it's like a it's just a stupid joke it's
never funny it's not supposed to be
funny to wish you a happy birthday
but yeah anyway Happy Thanksgiving
everybody
um a lot to be thankful in my life this
year and uh I love y'all
so we got a lot to talk about today
obviously I'm going to war with with uh
with uh let's just say crit for now to
keep you guys interested
be fun though Tim pool is advocating for
literally he's he's down Temple and
Tucker Carlson and I would even say a
large portion of the conservative base
now is just like
totally cool with
a gunman opening fire
and killing five people 17 injured at
Club Q because they had a drag show all
of it
I actually I thought higher of Tim Poole
I thought he was more reason I mean I
listen I think he's a [ __ ] goon
but I didn't think he was this crazy
yeah it's a his tweet was like something
you'd expect from Crowder Walsh or one
of those people Walsh yeah
Walsh is the worst even worse than
Crowder you know what I mean yeah that
golly man you know what you know what
the problem is though it's definitely
not me right right okay Temple and why
he's single
and lots of Twitter updates apparently
I'm about to get unbanned so oh we were
joking right before the show went live
so apparently he's considering an
amnesty
for
all banned accounts who did not
participate in spam
or law breaking lawbreaking well
according to Kaya I stole his identity
so
it's a serious crime that is a serious
crime won't be going to jail for that
um but if I do we were joking I wonder
if I should just tweet out the same
exact [ __ ] thing I am super for that
the same Epstein tweet
don't change my name
or profile picture because my profile
stuck as Elon Musk since I got banned I
can't change the profile or the name so
it's still Elon Musk Elon Musk
so kind of fire just like yo double
kamikaze
I don't know
oh AB is really stepping up back there
on the sound bites
do a little trolling huh
just a little bit and so there's that
potential but love on the other hand is
saying no we need your account we need
the juice so um
and the only one who doesn't find this
funny yeah yeah I don't like this at all
I need the juice like my job if if
Twitter is going under I don't have a
job anymore either so that's pretty
pretty tough I'm kidding I'm kidding
that was a joke
but no it's not I'm not joking no you're
definitely gonna get fired five minutes
yeah I'm just kidding of course no
um one thing I could do is put parity in
the title and then continue forth as a
permanent Elon Musk parody account where
I just have parody in the title I'm
looking forward to this
actually I'm gonna be happy to be back
on Twitter
really Ethan
yes quartering really bro take a shower
thanks Ethan I have this feeling that
you won't get unbanned okay
if if I don't get unbanned and that's
also epic I mean nobody can possibly say
after that that
I'm being like over the top when I say
he personally right went out of his way
to ban me
um we shall see we shall see
what's the status on that tweet right
now do you put up a poll or some [ __ ] he
did so what's the results there let's
take a look I'm just skipping ahead a
little bit got it down in the Twitter
section here
here we go I mean it's going to be yes
right who's going to vote knowing that
uh
uh there's 20 hours left with 1.7
million votes should I vote Yes or no
yeah of course vote yes no
oh yeah
yeses have it let's go
call Elon Musk parody account is back
baby
stuff about it
I saw Love's reply
I really need you to get something dude
wait what did you reply
uh for Ethan and Ela Klein don't put
that he's gonna see that right [ __ ]
do a carve out for us dude you're gonna
get us You're Gonna Get Us permanently
banned with that kind of [ __ ] I'm
building hype bro I'm building
so that'll be fun actually I really look
forward to doing a Elon Musk parody
my account parody parody parody
seriously for real not the real Elon
Musk
by the way I saw someone get banned
their name was Elon Musk and then
parentheses real right it's like
seriously dude
okay whatever so that's that let's move
on shall we but Happy Thanksgiving yada
yada
Bob's your uncle and all the a better
visitor you guys said oh Shredder got a
visitor oh cute goddamn rascal
darn garment Mr red you're so sweet how
you guys all have big Thanksgiving plans
what's on the horizon uh not doing them
the typical family stuff going out to to
Ventura to visit and all that good stuff
so where are you going in Ventura
that's where I'm from originally yeah
for those who don't know everyone else
Thanksgiving plans ticket prices were
insane it was two thousand dollars for
me Lena to go home just oh [ __ ] that
they can eat turkey by themselves yeah
does your family do turkey or do they
cook some other stuff oh they got turkey
yeah yeah
we my uncle really wanted us to go he
was even gonna pay for half of our
ticket but we're like yeah it's just not
worth the hassle because we're going
next month so there you go
[ __ ] it
all right
love that
um Teddy fresh Black Friday sale is
ending I think on Sunday actually I'm
not sure so if you guys want some
discounted Teddy fresh stuff head on
over there's a bunch of good stuff here
I'm literally gonna take the teddy fresh
away okay all right well get it before
keemstar does whatever happened with
that
what was he gonna sue me for I forgot
um I think it was after murder I think
it was after he lost uh
G fuel oh
shut up popping off about a house he's
gonna take the teddy fresh show and take
the teddy fresh
well um and also just a reminder that if
you guys want to support the crew and
get our wonderful pack of trading cards
these are available until December 2nd
yes third go ahead love you know more
than me
December 3rd 12 EST how many have we
sold well has he kept has he updated any
you guys
I haven't actually heard an update this
week yet um but as of last week there
was quite a bit uh let's forget how many
packs it was like
do we not we don't have an updated
number so I can ask I can let you know
it's fine it doesn't matter but anyway
guys this is a great gift but thank you
to everybody that bought it yeah
100. 5 trillion worth of cards I see
here trillion dollars worth of cars okay
yeah
we are all money all right so anyway
whatever so let's move on we got to
address actually the elephant in the
room
um The Claw in the room if you would we
got so [ __ ] canceled by white claw
Gabe
um I'm not even gonna say they're fans
of his they're fans of ours who are
deeply saddened deeply deeply
traumatized I think a lot of these
people have birthday trauma a little bit
that they're projecting but that's not
an excuse
there's a lot of you know birthdays are
hard
can I just say at the top yeah everyone
was super mad that nobody went to Gabe's
birthday
and like 90 of the comments were people
talking about uh how what were scum we
are people are so angry dude nobody's
mad at me
um do you they should be no you told me
privately you were gonna go no I didn't
say that I'm sorry about your dad
passing away
you're mistaken
Weasley little liar dude anyway yes so
people were so angry at us and I guess
we did [ __ ] up but I have to tell you
guys one
someone said yeah lots of people are
saying they're mad at you Dan nice try
one
um
I think we we all intended to go but
Zach bailed to go see the one the well
life once in a lifetime event of seeing
the Pink Floyd coming up man no he's
going to see Pink Floyd right uh the
cover oh it was a cover band yeah look
at a bowling alley or something
so it wasn't even the real Pink Floyd uh
I don't believe uh Gilmore or uh Waters
was there
is my understanding
and I think the keyboardist is dead so I
don't think he was there so and then I
guess Abe and Lena were gonna go and
then
I guess you guys kind of got cold feet
from Zach not being there you guys were
it was it was we had a lot going on and
first off let me say last year was one
of the funnest nights of my life like we
his family is beautiful we just fit in
right away they were so welcoming We Had
the Time of Our Lives we all really
sincerely wanted to go
um but yeah no we
a bunch of us had stuff coming up uh Ian
and Sam had a flight the next day like
super early uh I forget what was going
on but yeah it was it turned out it was
just going to be me Lena and cam at one
point and me it's a party yeah
I don't know we were going back and
forth so much and I was at the gym and I
didn't think anyone else was going by
the time other people were ready and I
was I got beaten up pretty bad I was all
sweaty and I was like oh [ __ ] it but let
me tell you guys Gabe is a lot more
popular than any of us here trust me
it's no shortage of people there like he
his party is packed like I wish I had
that many people come to my birthday
[ __ ] yeah he was so [ __ ] popular and
also he's like a 51 for the or does that
were 53 or something 51. he's like a
grown-ass [ __ ] man and that
dude has more friends than any all ever
met in your life that dude is
practically the pope how popular he is
you know what I mean and so
um
I don't think we ruined his birthday
party like a lot of y'all maybe thought
but they're all excuses we don't make
excuses here Abby we own it okay to
check okay we owning it don't be a fake
friend dude you're a fake just own it
I'm sorry Gabe [ __ ] weirdos straight
up
are you all in Chat thing oh you guys
are [ __ ] weirdo full story L fake
friend Doug and then here's a weird
thing I'll just be honest okay I'll just
be real about myself I said I was going
I was never gonna go
I don't leave my [ __ ] house okay I I
was gonna go I was gonna go but like
it's I have kids it cup is it's Friday
night you have two young kids you've
done you it's like the longest [ __ ]
day ever we don't have a babysitter it's
like I know that it's impossible for me
for me to do anything uh if you combine
with my general laziness and social
anxiety and also having family and kids
and a wife and also that
you know a billion other stuff you got
to let me off the hook now A B doesn't
have [ __ ] to do oh I'm under the bus
after that I have my hands full okay
like come on I thought for sure that one
of y'all would be there to document it
for the show I mean it was kind of your
job right so a b is to blame I didn't do
anything wrong
are you saying you want me to just go
for Content yeah I mean yeah in part
that's why you went the first time
that's worse Gabe is your Gabe is your
best friend maybe you guys you know I
was walking around like a Jehovah
Witness here the other day trying to
recruit everyone to go I really wanted
to [ __ ] go I really want to go yeah
cam are you sick I well I don't the
thing is I don't Camp should get no
blame here that's why you say if you get
the sick pass you're good no no I don't
I don't really know Gabe that well and I
didn't go to the party last year so it
would have been weird because everybody
already bailed at that point if you
scroll if you rolled by yourself I get
that pulled up just us too I felt like
it wouldn't have made the totally get
that totally get that yeah and also I'm
not I'm not I can't go by myself either
I need like you know what I mean I need
like I I can't just sit there and be by
myself I need like so you know I'm
scared to do that but also I have kids
nobody else here has kids two young kids
okay
blameless Ethan the blameless Ethan the
absolved
Sam and Ian real quiet over there
don't start with us dude don't even no
we we really wanted to go we literally
had a 9 A.M flight the next morning and
we got home we got back home late from
here we hadn't packed our cats hadn't
eaten they were out of food we had so
much stuff to do and I was like I want
to go but I don't think that it's
reasonable also we put in our GPS and it
was going to take us over an hour to get
there that's another thing we were just
leaving work and we had to go home
change that's an hour to get home an
hour to get to the party
it ain't easy so so yeah you got you
exactly I need my squad you guys are
right you got I need my squad I'm not
like you know I'm not it's not like you
know Bill Clinton can't just Cruise he
needs the Secret Service he needs the
protection it's all up up against the
Escalades uh it's like that for me dude
it was awesome last year like the uh his
brother-in-law the actor from The
Longest Yard I'm sorry I always forget
his name but he gave me an Ian like some
cigars from his private uh collection it
was we were chilling we were vibing we
had a great time I would have loved to
have gone how many of these people
that are upset about this how many of
you went to the party yeah
good question how many of you have a
[ __ ] brain
whoa oh come on now
we are working to put a show on for you
people with their human beings if they
have brains
by the very definition of being a human
I mean I was gonna fly out if you guys
went yes
but then like everyone just played yeah
yeah those were my favorite comments
someone said I know if love was there he
would have gone you could see it in his
eyes I'm like dude people yeah no people
get so deep with the analysis and the
projecting of their own insecurities of
uh but like at the end of the day
uh so so basically so Ian and Sam had an
early flight okay I never said I never
said I was going Dan never said he was
going Ian it seems to me you could have
stepped out and it said hi
I'm just [ __ ] with you because you
got so defensive Ethan at least I'm one
for two okay you're oh for two
I don't go anywhere bro I don't go to my
own birthday party I don't go to any of
those birthday parties like who'll
expect me to show up anywhere it's
ridiculous I'm old for everything stop
it I have kids okay kids you understand
two young boys two yes two cats two
babies two little fur babies that's true
a b doesn't even have pets
um
or early flight I want to go next here
to Gabe's party though real bad now well
now we better have like you know 100 I
mean we might not be invited again to be
honest after this debacle good point
um you know what I was saying and you
all thought it was a bad idea uh I said
listen he said he wants to eat a girl
out he's 51 it's about time I said I
said here I'm gonna make it up to him
and send them out to the Bunny Ranch in
Vegas where it's legal prostitution
what what's wrong with that it's illegal
I've support sex workers let's send him
out there I'll pay for the whole thing
we'll record it obviously
what not that it's like the journey
you can't handle the flock again let's
get him out there eat some [ __ ] you
know uh vaginas just to be totally Frank
and make this guy's dreams come true
there's nothing wrong with that in fact
I think it's a beautiful story of coming
to age he's coming to age story he's
coming talk about vodka
that's so good dude thank you I love
that [ __ ]
dude can we just do a poll like how many
people are in favor of white Club game
Journey to uh
uh Bunny Ranch Las in Nevada like what's
wrong with that I genuinely they're sex
workers they're in a legal environment
where the conditions are safe and good
there's literally I I want to do a poll
I'm serious
are you
are you for or are you for Ethan sends
Gabe to the Bunny Ranch Yes or No Escape
to the bunny I want to make it up to him
I want to make it up to him yes so this
is seems like the best way I mean let's
make dreams come true you know what I
mean I mean it's the only way really
like I just don't think it's a bad idea
I think it's awesome if he's down of
course you know it's up to him but I
think that's awesome
dude that would be such a great [ __ ]
that's it you see that the people are on
my side
I was getting naysayed when I pitched
this people calling you dobrik
yeah dilbrick if he went and sent his
friends to Heaven selflessly
how is this dobric I'm not putting him
on a [ __ ] tractor and running them
over sending them to to fulfill one of
his dreams bro
okay Ethan how is this strange
I mean 70 say yes so
I'm feeling pretty good about this
like like Jenny I'm asking genuinely
because I don't want to step in it on
this what's wrong with this idea if he's
down
what's wrong what's actually
wrong
oh this is kind of weird why
this is weird I don't know
just kind of feels it's gonna get
demonetized you're in the minority my
dude that's fine I agree how is it I see
the polls
I wasn't icky I genuinely don't I don't
know it's just it's just weird and
especially yeah it's making content out
of that is I don't have to send a camera
we can just send them and this is weird
stick your finger I mean I didn't you
didn't have to stick but I acknowledge
I'm in the minority here and all the
people that are
all the people that are uh Colin dobrik
I mean the poll is the pole it's a good
pull what can I do okay let's do let's
do another poll is Ethan being though
brick right now
puts his people at risk I'm just trying
to send this guy to [ __ ] yeah I mean
this would be consensual and and I
assume the sex worker would not be
blackout drunk so it's not actually
comparable to that situation at all
that's why I assume the sex workers
friend in Disguise no no there's no
tricks these all they're not human
trafficked for the record either
uh is Ethan being a dobrik right now
dude I don't know man the thing is like
70 say yes but the the minority are
making me feel
uncomfortable with it
I'm obviously gonna vote no
100 no that's what I see right now
oh come on you guys all right Gabe just
missed out on the dream on the trip of a
lifetime all on me
so there you go how much do you guys
actually love Gabe I question it
right I question it
hmm how am I exploiting his personal
life dude come on he's gonna have to
agree to do it he's 51 guys he's a grown
[ __ ] man
some of you guys like infantile
infantize him a lot and it's almost like
reverse
it's just weird how dare you guys talk
about our audience
I didn't say they had no brains baby I
mean he took it too far I didn't say all
of them
I don't have to record it I don't have
to record it
you know what I mean
I mean obviously I'll ask him about it
can I do that at least you [ __ ]
yeah
that's okay yeah I'll just ask him about
it
yeah I'll just say how was it Gabe no Oh
I thought you meant whether or not he's
interested obviously he's got to agree
I'm not going to kidnap him and then
[ __ ] so is that
is it okay for you to ask
like that we talk about pooping and
buttholes all day it's like nothing I
can't talk to Gabe about
well 53 says that you're dobrik so
that's pretty close that doesn't really
that doesn't really match up with the
previous poll
I think they're like I like it that he's
dobrik right now there's 20 who are
pro-do bro I think Don changed their
mind a little bit yeah Dan okay everyone
it for Gabe I'm sorry Gabe I don't know
I'm not saying don't do it I just you
are fighting that no you asked me you
said my you asked dude it just seems
kind of gross so cool
all right you want him to die never
eating out a girl Dan I see how it is
you [ __ ] I mean just say you hate gay
bro you gotta earn that
you gotta earn that right yeah and I'm
paying for it for him that's why it's
gross about it he's 51 bro it's like uh
he wouldn't he's running out of time
dude it broke my heart when he was like
so you're against sex work is what
you're saying just come out and say it
you hate sex workers it's like paying
for a driver's license bro it's not
right yeah that's what that's what sex
work is you guys wow I don't have a
problem with that aspect of it the man's
51 he's running out of time it broke my
heart you said I said you ever go down
on a girl he says no I'd like to try it
someday he says you're 51 Gabe
I mean you gotta get we gotta make a
move on this he did say you want to try
it someday
all right we're moving on
thank God
Dan you're not Progressive enough for
this conversation
you're conservative uh it's true beliefs
are showing yeah
oh yeah I wanted to read some of the
comments because they're they're so CR
they're they're really mad I can't
believe no one went to Gabe's birthday
but it made me so sad
someone said they were crying it makes
my heart heard that oh okay y'all better
make it up to Gabe I'm trying but nobody
wants me wait somebody really said they
were crying yeah there was did you grab
that one that's not no they said I'm
literally cover the username or
something okay that's true that's yeah
that person's getting bullied all right
well it had a lot of uploads
poor Gabe didn't deserve to be dish you
mean to tell me that like every single
person showed prior plans
lame friend Moon not every single person
why did crew not go to games before he
hurt my heart so badly
it's actually upsetting you guys didn't
go he's so sweet let me get this
straight you all hyped oh so this one it
really hits hard man let me get this
straight y'all hyped your boy game up
every Friday for the past year then
y'all hyped up his b-day live on last
week's podcast saying you were gonna go
in front of thousands of people and yet
no one showed up that's tacky as hell
damn you know what you got it that one
you know what
that's a more calling it tacky I think
is fair
I think it was a little tacky
oh God no but I'm just I'm saying that
there's there's there's a spectrum here
and somebody's sobbing on Gabe's behalf
is with peace and love a little bit too
much but to say it's tacky I mean that's
a fair opinion to have I feel
like tacky isn't that harsh I I just
want to know tacky's harsh she she that
one will hit hard that one hurt that one
hurt really because it was real it was
real you know what I mean right I guess
well because it's accurate exactly
but I do want to I do wonder if Faith
knew that like we weren't the only
attendees
because like there was a whole shitload
of people there gave dessert so much
better than us oh my God yeah I wonder
if they know how packed it was last year
and we were sitting alone in the corner
at first for a while just us because
he's so damn popular yeah you guys were
not like the guests of honor or anything
no no there were other influencers there
too there were like big tick tockers
there uh we weren't even the most
popular people in his life Charlie
demilio was there dancing and doing [ __ ]
where you know Gabe deserves so much
better than us [ __ ] I'd be so hurt if my
friends got in front of thousands of
people and snickered about why they
ditched we didn't do that
with peace and love we did not do that
yeah wait we didn't even talk about it
until today what are they no we talked
about it and that's when people got mad
is on Monday we were talking about oh
you're right you're right yeah
we weren't doing that come on now
poor Gabe does so much for you guys and
yeah okay all right oh this is the one
about okay that's a
wait hold on there's so much this is the
only correct comment
yeah Gabe does so much for us I mean he
calls in for five minutes once a week
how many not that I don't appreciate it
but it's like that again that's so much
also he gets oh I mean I'll say Ethan I
got it I got it I got this uh Gabe is
top on Cameo did you guys know that
do you guys how do you how do you do
that I wonder how he [ __ ] he did that
people think about it well he
he's pretty big on Tick Tock baby yeah
yeah yeah
well yeah Evie's mad Amy's really upset
no I don't I'm playing but
just use your brain
um well this is my fave this one goes
I'm almost certain love would have gone
to Gabe's part I can see how bad it's
about when they said none of them went
just another reason he's one of my faves
dude they have an old narrative about
you they have a whole list of reasons
why they're in his eyes he looks
heartbroken and he would totally have
gone he's my favorite that's like when
um max and I dropped the egg twice
people were like wow you could see like
how devastated love was about it like he
would have never done that he cared so
much about that child you murdered Iggy
eggy and eggy too I have some
some Die Hard oh look who's here love
you guys look who's here the little boy
the little boy oh you're so cute
little [ __ ] it's Brucey baby
and they say he's a mini me Twins and
they're right they're so cute oh this is
my microphone
you got the hiccups yeah it is on the
mic if you don't hear him
yeah Teddy's here we brought our the
family to work today because Teddy
doesn't have um yeah school all week you
want to say something he says Abba
that's his one word
oh you hear that Teddy so we gave Teddy
a mic and we're not going to show his
face obviously Teddy say you want to say
hi to everybody
call him right here daddy say hi
hi
sweetheart I love you
is it enough are you having fun at work
I want to go with Mommy and Daddy I'm
gonna come sit with you Mommy's coming
over here right now yeah oh hi Mom all
right yeah Mommy will come sit with you
so that um
I'm pretty you're so funny you want to
say something into the mic you want to
say Abba you wanna show them how you
talk
you hear that his first word is ABBA
yeah he's a sweet at heart oh my God
shout out to the dancing queen wants to
know what Bruce
what's your brother's name I refuse to
believe that he's just a big Abba fan he
likes Dancing Queen the best yep yeah
okay see you later bubs
so Teddy are you having fun at the
office
yeah
yeah yeah yeah who's watching you
and you're hanging out with Elena you
guys are best friends huh
Abby and Lena
what were you guys doing back there you
have that little play Space where you
guys playing with like arcade game or
something
he's being shy
hey are you being shy sweetie
yeah right here there you go
Teddy is there something you want to
talk about
he's adjusting the mic he wants it to be
perfect yeah better Mike he's very
particular he is I'm not even kidding
let's see here we go go ahead Teddy let
me know when you're ready okay and then
we can
you know you'd leave it Michael okay
there you go
Oh I wanna do this I wanted to move like
this no no maybe or someone narrate
what's going on there all right so he's
he's adjusting the mic downwards but I'm
not sure exactly Teddy you need help or
you got it I want to do this but it's
not going up okay here let me come help
you real fast I know what he wants I
think he wants to hold it like you hold
yours at home hold on
oh you want to hold it like that okay
cool nice
this is next-gen families podcast
yay Teddy got his mic cool that's so
cute is that how you wanted it Teddy
yeah okay cool is there holds your mic
like this
so tell me um
is there something you'd like to discuss
on the show today Teddy yeah what you
been into lately
what do you want to talk about
[Music]
maybe I'll ask you a question
[Music]
Teddy locket launcher maybe I'll ask you
a question okay
Teddy can you tell me
what does the dentist do
yeah
wow okay that's a good answer
all right let me hit let me hit you with
bad street comedy videos let me he
doesn't want my help holding the
microphone he keeps pushing my hand away
okay yeah buddy yeah
okay let me ask you another question one
this one's gonna be even harder okay
what does a front loader do
it's good it Scoops up dead wow
wow it sure does
okay okay interesting and then let me
ask you this
who is Daddy's
mom
yeah
okay I get that well ma Ila is your
mommy who's Daddy's Mommy
grandma Grandma
Donna wow
that's so good a hundred points
okay all right all right and let's say
What is daddy's favorite food
Daddy's food daddy food that's
technically true yeah that's technically
true not incorrect Theodore knows
everything there is to know about
dinosaurs yeah
what's your favorite
wait pterodactyl is your favorite
Oh I thought it was stegosaurus that
changed recently
got it
is that right
you gotta Shuffle the dinos yeah
who's the scariest dinosaur in the world
T-Rex yeah definitely easy Rex easily
and why is the T-Rex so scary
because it has a teeth yeah
yeah sharp teeth big clot does he have
big claws
small claws
is he fast is the T-Rex fast no oh he's
not let's do that goes fast wow that's
true they are fast huh
and so do you think a
do you think a Triceratops would be
afraid of a T-Rex
yeah yeah
why is it
afraid of the T-Rex they're all afraid
they're all afraid of the T-Rex what
about a Spinosaurus would he be afraid
of the T-Rex no okay he's dead he's big
he's Spinosaurus yeah he's bigger than a
T-Rex actually
yeah that's that's a good insight
Ela asked what's the tallest dinosaur
oh
the spinosaurus is very big but I
actually don't think the spinosaurus is
the tallest dinosaur ever
the T-Rex is also very tall what's the
one with the really long neck
bronchiosaurus is that the right and
there's one that's even taller than
bronchiosaurus you remember
wow
love that love that
love it
Teddy what do you Teddy what do you want
to do when you get older
do the podcast oh no no no no no steer
them away
you want to work with Daddy on the
podcast or do you want to have your own
podcast yeah
you want to have your own podcast or you
want to do it with daddy with daddy okay
that sounds nice I think that'd be fun
that'd be great what should we talk
about
should we do a show about
maybe about Paw Patrol
I just realized he could hear himself
through the speaker so he's doing a
little bit of fun
hey will you tell us a joke Teddy
a fart sound
pretty good
woke up the monster and then the monster
just on the way with the whites and then
the lights sounded
the lights farted
the light shouted yeah wow that's good
that's a good joke
[Applause]
who makes the largest farts of our
family
thank you respect game recognized game
mommy says mommy hates when I do a fart
game but should I do you think I should
stop or do you think it's funny because
you always smile when I do it
you like the fart game or no
he's looking at Mom Fernando Mom don't
don't game the system don't listen to
Mommy on this one you you tell me what's
in your heart
we like the fart game maybe we'll decide
another day
it's a big decision you know to put him
on the spot like that
okay
if you had a garden Teddy what what
would you want to grow in it
foreign
grapes oh yeah but we don't we don't get
to eat grapes at home why is that
what's happening we're having a little
bit microphone right now okay
I thought he said legs
legs what happened did Mike drop mic
drop moment Teddy how come we don't get
to have grapes at home
what
[Music]
we got the dogs
because the dogs dogs can't eat grapes
right
joining the mic like Daddy wait Teddy
what else can't dogs eat
is you are you losing is he losing
attention yeah
yeah all right Teddy thank you it's been
such a pleasure to hear from you my
beautiful son
uh everybody loves you
bye sweetheart we love you
[Applause]
you can chime in though if you want
throughout the show just if you have
something to say you go ahead and uh
just let a b know okay or Lena or Mommy
there it is Theodore Klein my son
Theodore everybody and Bruce of course a
round of applause the kid
he's a natural what can you say
Ela uh bleached your eyebrows
um I don't know if you guys saw
oh you guys just thought she was here I
think it's it's dope I think it's cool
it's adventurous it's wild I says Ela do
it because
why not who's gonna say no who's going
to stop you you know what I mean who's
gonna fire you nobody I think they're
bomb live your life
my mom
why'd you do that to your eyebrush eye
brush
the thing is you can always die in back
hi Bruce whoa
whoa hey you're funny I'm just gonna die
back when I get tired of it yeah yeah
it's an easy fix fortunately
um
so there you go
uh so we congratulate Ela Avi of course
Eli there's been some unfortunate
comparisons I don't know if you want to
see these
uh I mean you know Marilyn Manson uh
minus the r word allegations we're
talking just yeah just eyebrows
but is his bleach or are they gone I
think they're just shaved yeah that guy
don't have any eyebrows I mean
they're hard to see you I'm to be fair
on ela's face they're hard to see
um murder Mommy I agree
if you scroll down it shows the
uh star Kayla says I was wrong it looks
slay
reacting to me lying
my regenerine reaction to that
transformation okay whatever so there it
is that's fun we love uh an adventurous
Queen don't we folks yes yes yes
um
take him yo I gotta say I've been on
YouTube shorts because we started
posting shorts
on our on our main YouTube page how's
that been going it's been going okay
right love I mean yeah I mean it's doing
okay they have it still early they
haven't hit super hard but
for that reason I've been watching
shorts more and more and the amount of
Andrew Tate shorts is absolutely nuts
dude even on YouTube where he's been
banned it's like crazy shut up okay
but here's one I saw
the fan cams are
getting really weird like check this
[ __ ] out
uh
yeah it has copyright music so check
this out
um
Tate treats only fan model to a trip to
but Dubai and then he picks up an
eight-year-old kid
this fan taking an eight-year-old only
fans bottle
is that weird I guess it's her but I
don't know
looked like he was taking a kid bro [ __ ]
yes I'm not no not cool
this is the account best Tate speech now
I don't want to be weird about it but
like these guys are all super homophobic
and Hyper masculine and the amount that
they that his fans are posting like his
nude body and like almost like sexy fan
cams of him they're really I feel wanna
[ __ ] Andrew
that's the game like I genuinely they
they're projecting I want to [ __ ] Andrew
big time
stop it was your Tick Tock feed have to
say about that
no yeah he's not on my Tick Tock no on
your phone right now oh Tick Tock oh
yeah here we go y'all you wanna [ __ ]
Andrew like oh they're all the tater
tots are in my chat now it's so
interesting because you can see the live
numbers and it starts at about a
thousand then it goes down to like a
hundred because obviously it's like a
horrible shot there's no really
redeeming reason to watch here they all
go to YouTube but then you can see it
starts to go up again like right now
it's at 500 and it can go up to like a
thousand and it's all Tater haters hell
yeah
you're weird Ethan
well you're here so you're here how
weird is that yeah
um do you guys want to [ __ ] Andrew it
just seems like
I get that Vibe sometimes
you know
who am I to judge so Andrew taking a
eight-year-old boy out for a dream
vacation just the two of them
that's crazy wait Andrew on coffee let's
see is he Pro coffee
before coffee and caffeine we were
living our lives in rhythm with the sun
we got up when the sun came up we went
down when the sun couldn't go against it
did she just makes it up it's awesome
that's kind of the power of being a guru
if you speak with confidence people will
reward you
we didn't go against it very much with
the Industrial Revolution and caffeine
the introduction of caffeine we now had
night shifts we now had double shifts
think about this if a job introduces a
coffee break if the company says take
maybe electricity and like light no bro
it was the coffee with that it's coffee
and prior to that I mean there were like
candles it was impossible to stay up
without coffee I was curious I'm kind of
curious what people did in the northern
hemisphere where it's like three hours
of daylight they didn't get a lot done
they were just yeah they didn't get on
short days that's what we're going
without coffee we're all doomed I'd like
by the way coffee is not that [ __ ]
helpful I just am I the only one if you
got to stay up all goddamn night it's
not like coffee is like crap story are
you
I don't know how that is I was gonna say
I agree you know what I do drink though
is uh gamer Subs well gamer sub makes it
Gamers up Nation I've heard the
productivity human productivity has been
up five thousand percent since gamer sup
was invented absolutely I've been
staying up all nights double shifts
triple ships quadruple [ __ ] so it's
another Industrial Revolution and before
they just went off the Sun
oh
no what do I do
yeah now all of a sudden we're going
back to the Moon NASA's going back to
the Moon is that a coincidence no gamer
sub what the [ __ ]
I let it slide when you were throwing
out some hate on coffee but I'm seeing
in the chat all these coffee haters
what's going on listen I like coffee
I'll drink it but it doesn't do anything
it's so [ __ ] exaggerated
coffee if anything it makes me tired I
agree it's not I'm not doing double
shifts thanks to coffee
I know what it's supposed to do and I
like the taste but I could take a nap
exactly exactly why are you stop working
and drink this coffee that's because the
coffee you have is worth the time they
let you not work because you make up for
it plus something that's how powerful it
is my entire reality is confident
caffeinated
I'm sorry but this is beta Behavior
I love coffee so much I like it with
straws and I like it with pumpkin spice
and I like it with special little
whipped creams and the little and the
cute little leaf they do in the espresso
but yeah this is beta baby bro I don't
need coffee I live on [ __ ] air oxygen
[ __ ] oxygen keeps me awake because I'm
not a beta excuse me I need to blow my
nose
that that that that that that that
don't you agree
I bet he likes the little I like the
little leaf I like hearts in my the top
of my cappuccinos
isn't he saying he doesn't need coffee
because his bloodstream is is caffeine
or whatever the [ __ ] he's trying to oh
is that what he's saying I think so
without caffeine no years no he says I
haven't been awake in years without
caffeine he's a child he's a baby I
gotcha I used to drink coffee every
single day so I thought about this yo
that's hardcore bro he drank coffee
every day whoa nobody in the world does
that whoa this dude knows that a bird he
is hardcore
probably with only one sugar too huh
hardcore maybe life's better without
caffeine so I took a week off of coffee
and there was just zero Advantage I
didn't sleep any better I didn't feel
like I could focus as well so after a
week I had a cup of coffee and it was
like the miracle is back there's nothing
bad about caffeine but I have 10 to 15
coffees a day every single day and I
will oh let's go I love Andrew now
before Yeah Boy by the way he's right
there's nothing wrong with coffee
actually Studies have shown if anything
coffee is good for you uh so I'm totally
Pro coffee I just think the effects are
exaggerated but that being said he's
beta as a [ __ ] no this is a base
take his first and only base take 15
cups of coffee a day let's [ __ ] go
wait how much is that like actually it's
a lot that's like every that's like two
an hour during your waking hours well he
doesn't sleep apparently he's like yo I
don't [ __ ] I do quadruple chips every
night
uh it's awesome
I guess he's a simp for coffee so there
it is I mean I drink a lot of coffee but
not 10 to 15 cups a day I don't think
three or four let's be real
yeah
um so there's that so congratulations to
the kid he took on a private vacation
together that's really romantic I mean
inspiring
by the way do you think this is a
coincidence Charlie demilia one Dancing
with the Stars by the way is this you
know what I feel about coincidences okay
yeah there's no such thing I know but do
you think that
I feel like this whole competition is
not fair you have Rudy Giuliani versus
Charlie demilio this Dancing with the
Stars wait that's not oh definitely he
was on the mass singer right okay oh
yeah but I was gonna say they got Rudy
on Dance
that he did a number on Master but I'm
saying they bring out like these washed
up [ __ ] like 55 year old decrepit
sealess celebrities and then Charlie
demilio who's like a professional dancer
of course you're gonna win
yeah but true right but she's in the
front of these colors and apparently the
song referenced Frenemies yeah the like
first line is we used to be Frenemies or
something oh that has to be intentional
but she hates Trisha they had like a
whole few days yeah I remember well she
had tap dancing on on the show's grave
yeah yeah she deserves that stunting on
us honestly colors
I like I like Charlie she seems nice I I
have no problem with her you know what I
mean
she had like a totally
unproblematic rise to fame and Trisha
was such a b word to her yeah you're
gone to Ethan uh so I stand
Charlie forever Frenemies forever girl
if you're watching Charlie
I'm sure she is
get this to Charlie that's hey that's my
thing I you know I put those colors
together so show some respect or I'll
come for you next
just kidding
people in the costume people are saying
uh
shangella Shangela
IDE Angela wait who's the Angela I I
guess uh they were also in the
competition and Charlie
what kind of name is Shangela she's a
drag queen
oh so it's not a real it's not like a
birth name or it is no no I'm pretty
sure that's not her oh Shangela let me
see Shangela let's see Shangela Dancing
with the Stars oh and then also the
winners decided by fan voting see I mean
that's also not fair shangela's real
name is Darius Jeremy Pierce okay
that's Angela okay well I haven't seen
her dancing but uh I watched the finale
Shangela delivered the best performance
I've ever seen on them
so she was wrong so was it just a fan
vote that took that gave Charlie I think
it's a combination of the judges scores
and the fan votes but I'm not really
sure how that works but no shangelo was
incredible they had like High Caliber
dancers and season was Charlie's good
though at least yeah yeah I mean
Charlie's great I mean she's a
professional dancer yeah you know so I
love it
damn Shangela
I I got this I got the scent of a new
friend of me show Shangela and Charlie
reach out hit me up
all right so let's talk about crit you
know when we got him all click baited in
the title so let's just do this
yeah obviously again I'll just say eager
they said I don't have a problem with
crit I like critical he's funny he's
he's a good guy by all accounts but his
friend Kaya is a big [ __ ] tool
previous episode on Monday we talked
about Kyle Orson one of his co-hosts on
his podcast talking about uh why I got
banned on Twitter
wait why is this have a picture of okay
maybe it's just weird wrong
um
talking about why I got banned and just
straight up lying about me
he said I'm doing identity theft because
I changed my name to Elon Musk I mean
the man is
struggling to breathe people say that
breathing is a
automatic function of the body he's
forced to force every breath in and out
of his lungs because his brain just
can't handle that uh that function so he
struggles and stuff
but here he is talking about how I he's
simply I don't know bro just listen to
this idiot it's a recap God I got um
bands was like Ethan did he call me La
slime because I missed that the first
time yeah yeah yeah la slime yeah he's
got a big problem with LA people as
we'll see later yeah I think that's
another thing I see from like
conservative [ __ ] weirdos where they
go like California oh it was um
who tweeted out failed State of
California was that
yeah
oh it was Tate oh it's Tate yeah he oh
yeah failed State we're the fourth
biggest economy in the world California
just passed like the whole country of
Germany [ __ ] you know what I
mean we're the only state that has like
maternity leave and [ __ ] like that I
mean what's failed about this state I
love California and also oh somebody
said Turkish man hating L.A hmm that's
interesting that's a good point shout
out Finn wait what does that mean
there's a lot of Armenians in Los
Angeles but we didn't know that see
that's a deep cut I know what that meant
so you so you think this is an Armenian
I don't actually think that but I think
that's a that's a clever observation on
the part of that chatter my claw just uh
oh [ __ ] took it now
I got it
yeah
um
slime
dude
yeah I think you need a tool to uh
oh it's on the bottom what the rig here
hold this up yeah
what the [ __ ] we got we got the whole
game oh we have 800 people on Tick Tock
I told you guys it's crazy
um here are all the tater tots are in
the chat
walking l
top g l yeah I'm a sitting owl you idiot
loser
dude you guys are such idiots bro thank
you for being here I can't tell you how
much it means to me 900 now on Tick Tock
this is keemstar owns you damn we even
got keemstar fans in the chat let's keep
he took the teddy press he owns me
um sitting Al thank you at least for
being accurate about it this time guys
come join us on um hey you know be cool
come put hate comments on YouTube uh H3
podcast come join
and leave them there we'd love to see
you and actually if you want to leave a
comment you can do a two dollar donation
and say what's up
say whatever you want cool huh
I was gonna say also California knows
what the [ __ ] is up because number one
search podcast H3 baby
he burst is walking so cute look at that
he's getting really good at walking
what's up hi Bruce you're so good you
can show that I don't know if you have a
uh here I could do it on my uh phone
feed real quick
Brucey he's not skipping crawling and
going straight to
to walking and his brother oh my God
that's such a great shot Brizzy
show us how you walk yay
all he wants to do is stand and walk
this is a
he hates being on his stomach you put
him on his stomach and he'll he will
roll over immediately
no interest in crawling Prissy
you're doing so good buddy
you want to walk to Daddy come here
[Music]
you think you can make it all the way
over here whoa the doggies are here
can you see it Dan
um
the talks oh my God
oh what a guy
little fella what a little fella
cute oh freaking cute man we're off the
rails in a whole new way yeah and a much
more wholesome way yeah I'll take it
back
ready
you never know what you're gonna get
here on the ace3 podcast
look at that with the two dogs that's a
killer shot and a big smile
[Music]
we said let Bruce sit in Dan's chair
I don't think I don't think children
should be within like 15 20 feet of this
chair that thing is so sharp yeah
it's injured me several times at this
point yeah the tennis ball the tennis
ball helped a lot because that was the
main way but I've still I've banged my
knee on it and stubbed my toe and
all kinds of fun stuff all kinds of fun
stuff
oh alfredo
whoa whoa whoa getting a little wobbly
what
dude it's insane how much he looks like
it was so weird it's so weird
[Music]
it's just a miniature Ethan
careful of showing the screen
Teddy has entered the equation so we
have uh cut away temporarily
Ethan is looking so slay says gray Bibo
I'm sure he appreciates that oh yeah
great bibo says you look slay lots of
people are saying that I lost weight and
I'll say when I look in the mirror I
still see like a big fat [ __ ] ugh so
much fat it's like so much fat still but
this shirt I you know three months ago I
100 could not even fit in this shirt and
actually I fit
okay great in the shirt I feel good in
it keep it up this Dome is yours if you
hit that goal don't forget oh yeah I
know Dome is yours they say the proof is
in the pudding but in my case the proof
is outside the pudding
because I don't eat pudding anymore
right
thank you
thank you everybody
nope up some Applause please thank you
outside the pudding I said
all right be here all week be here all
year in fact okay so anyway we're
talking about Kaya so I'm a slime La
slime
at least slime ball don't they live in
Florida and I'm I'm I don't know if he
does I know crit does
but it's like bro if you have no idea he
if he's even I know current lives in
Florida so let's just say that it's like
if you're let's just assume he's in
Florida because his best deal is he's in
Turkey you know maybe not oh he's in
Turkey Maybe
never mind she's got well listen all I'm
saying is that if you are living in
Florida you got to be careful about what
you say about the other states
because it just so happens that not only
you in objectively the dumbest and the
shittiest state by far your lit state is
literally about to fall into the ocean
the next 10 years so like don't be
coming to California asking for
admission from your dumbass [ __ ]
literally sunken State you want to talk
about Fallen state you live in a sunken
State literally under the ocean
check get your elbows ready because I
love Florida I'm sorry I I have oh wait
wait wait he lives in Germany you mean
the fifth largest economy in the world
oh owl
yeah exactly California forever goodbye
that's that one guy on Tick Tock love
him goodbye anyway
yeah he got two points something million
followers again he went on his account
and basically tweeted hi I'm Elon and
I'm a pedophile I love Jeffrey Epstein
and his uh little babies that I used to
[ __ ] or whatever he got banned and look
here's two things they're both
Hypocrites Elon Musk should be able to
take a joke he's being a big baby but
also you're a hypocrite isn't this what
you said should happen
I don't want to be like an Elon dick no
we already went over it
I'm just gonna let it ride because I
pause it so much I'm just gonna let you
guys watch it all right that's not
really a joke it's like a straight up
defamatory statement you know well yeah
that's the distinction I was trying to
make with the other things too where
they were going on you know changing
their name to Elon Musk and making like
telling people to dump their stocks and
saying hey go vote for this candidate
like okay wait that's not a joke you're
actually impersonating someone now
you're not actually trying to defraud
people with this [ __ ] so fair enough if
you ban them again I feel like Elon is a
big baby but yeah but at the same time
like isn't this what you wanted Ethan
yeah I literally have no [ __ ] clue
the guy the man is so dumb I mean I
wouldn't be surprised if he's actually
sitting in an iron lung this processing
his breathing firm
thank you
said iron lung because he can't breathe
yeah no I got it it was it was clever
and I chuckled thanks yeah so he again
I'm just I'm getting so [ __ ] tired of
people lying about me obviously we
talked about this this is just the lead
I've been trying to give some background
here I'm so [ __ ] tired of people
lying it's just saying whatever the [ __ ]
they want about me it seems like so many
fandoms just hate me outside of this one
that has gotten to the point where you
can pretty much say I did anything and
people will just take it on face value
like there's no accountability at all
for these kind of for this kind of
[ __ ] so yeah this kind of take like
pissed me the [ __ ] off
and I corrected the record I was just
like Globe that's not what happened at
all
um
there's so much dumb they said though
they're like um
it's defamation
for me to tweet out that
a joke about Elon missing
Epstein like they just have no
perception of what defamation is like
how you're going to even conjure that
work it's so stupid you know better than
most well that's for [ __ ] fact first
of all I'm a comedian so anything I say
being considered defamation is almost
like impossible just straight out on its
face okay
um anyway so I called him out Kaya I
said the guy's you know kind of a dick
and he's lying about me
and instead of apologizing and
correcting the record he immediately
tweeted that I should kill myself with
the shotgun that I fantasize about
shooting people with
he erased it by the way coward coward he
said
here so that you don't defame him that
he hopes that you don't kill yourself in
a sarcastic way which obviously
read between them he says uh after
talking about his fantasies of unloading
his shotgun people I hope Ethan doesn't
end up turning it on himself
all right well adjusted Kaya and what's
interesting there's a lot of comments of
people who were like yo Kaya actually
ruins that podcast a lot of critical
fans were like I like the podcast I
would watch it but I had to stop because
the guy is just so obnoxious he actually
ruined it and that doesn't surprise me
at all actually because I mean listen
he don't think so good you know
and
um
so that was that he erased the Tweet
like a [ __ ] coward you know
and then he went on to
uh
he proceeded to go on I don't know where
these came from I guess someone's
knocking on him from Discord that's
awesome bro
see even your fans don't like you dude
they're straight up
they're straight up [ __ ] narking on
you dude
so he just calls me fat you know which
is the classic right calling it
defamation wasn't even from me mood
appointed it out that was what Ethan is
doing wasn't just parody I mean bro you
can't even keep what happens straight
that's obviously not what happened you
brought it up muda said something based
on what you said and so he caught a
little heat based on what you said bro
um he said but Fatboy wouldn't have the
sack to go after him so I got to be the
Fall Guy again did we when do we talk
about this do we already talk about this
or was that on was that on my Members
Only
yeah I think it was oh yeah
dude this is so [ __ ] dumb bro first
of all I made a whole video about Moodle
heart I mean the the claim that I don't
have a sack to go after mudahar is so
weird and crazy like you have you're
wrong at every sense of POS possible
um you said I was stealing his his
identity
and the reason that mudahar said it was
defamation is because your dumb [ __ ]
ass said that I tweeted
hi I'm Elon Musk and I'm a pedophile and
I [ __ ] kids so that's not what happened
and by the way even if I did that it
wouldn't even come close to defamation
it still wouldn't be defamation but it's
not but yeah I guess muda is going off
of what he's taking taking him as well
if Moodle looked dumb uh for saying that
it's entirely based on your [ __ ] take
of it Kaya you
oh God what is sipping beer just doesn't
seem responsible when you only have two
brain cells left you know what I mean
like he's taking care of his anxiety
three steps that's all it takes no but
I'm saying when you have two brain cells
left you really want to jeopardize
losing you know one of those because
it's not gonna be looking good just
saying
so taking sips in between reminding
yourself to breathe in it's just it's
part of the Rhythm it's risky and I want
them to be okay on like I want him to
experience everything but yeah
but yeah my fave is that he calls me fat
boy of course which is as everybody
knows the one and only wonderful insult
to make
against me fat man bad of course and um
look man look
and I love that for him now he called me
fat so I feel like it's fair game too
let's see what he looks like don't you
guys
let's see
this guy called me fat and uh
well
fat ugly and stupid this guy
this guy thinks I'm fat and ugly
apparently
well I'm assuming ugly right you said
fat man
I don't know what do you ladies think is
this dude cool to be calling people fat
I'm not putting a comment out it looks
he looks fit though
he looks like he's got muscles
so maybe he is right about me
maybe he's right you know
so [ __ ] I don't know
take it back
I take everything back he's he's
muscular and I'm well well before you
take it back look at what I highlighted
in the doc he didn't just come for you
he he committed the the sin of all sins
yeah of course so he goes it's
incredible how like these people they
know they don't learn I mean we need to
psychologically profile these people he
he calls me fat and then he and then he
goes after Ela
it's like it wasn't even there
she got nothing to do with it nothing
it's just [ __ ] incredible how do all
these guys follow the same Playbook oh
ela's coming she heard some [ __ ] what
the [ __ ] yeah you wanna you wanna come
you know about this guy Kaya oh you
don't you're in trouble now [ __ ]
you're in trouble
wait that uh hold on ela's here you're
[ __ ] busted dude we're not we're not
set up for that
um
what you want to see his original take
the clip yeah but the clip that started
it all let me show you what he said
about you okay he called me fat before
and then he goes whatever
he's obsessed with LA apparently
dude the insecurity is [ __ ] The
Fragile masculinity is oozing off this
dude what La does to a [ __ ]
I don't know what is the problem that I
put on makeup
you should be good boy that I'm sawyed
the [ __ ] out
you ugly what does he look like there we
go no I mean not great I'll just be
honest not great some people are saying
that he looked hot in the chat oh they
were okay
okay I don't know he's a little busted
in my opinion his face look a little
busted I'm just gonna be real
I have no idea who this is so I'm
curious this is him I mean I don't know
I'm not I'm not eager to suck his suck
him off or anything cool whatever
but he's fit so I was thinking well [ __ ]
if he's got muscles and I'm fat maybe I
don't know anything back love so I found
something love no uh oh what love fine
oh dude whatever oh man what Florida
does to a [ __ ] what Germany does
yo oh hi uh you got some answering to do
for this [ __ ] boy is that your homie
critical who by the way who's you the
fact that you even came up for air to
make these uh Discord messages after
sucking crit off for the career he's
giving you you need to [ __ ]
go down you breathe and you suck that's
your [ __ ] job in between podcasts
yeah but that's I got news for you that
means you're gay
that's so cringe bro you need to talk to
your friend crit about that makeup thing
yes so he says what L.A does to a
[ __ ] which is apparently me
having fun on my show
uh entertaining a million people making
a bunch of money having the best haircut
I've seen on a guy cool hair 2022 yeah
and then having an awesome fashionable
cool wife and our beautiful house
nice yard beautiful perfect dog
wife looks awesome beautiful
apparently this is what La does to a
[ __ ] I think more people should
move here yeah that sounds pretty good I
would do some people some good who
wouldn't want that I mean get out here
quick man because shit's popping or not
stay where you are I'm just saying it's
just popping depends who you are
I have no problem with Kaya staying
where he is apparently he's well he says
uh he called me an LA slime
I like slime Ethan Klein yeah look how
beautiful she is I think you look
[ __ ] awesome bro but he doesn't
apparently
am I right I don't care
what you should care what a random dude
thinks about your looks why don't why
wouldn't you care she's so [ __ ]
beautiful well Vin's gone yours if Vin's
got your back
you know how am I supposed to sit over
here oh there's more Ian
no shot there's more
so here's he posted a picture of you
who said geesh are you sure that looks
like Marilyn Manson I mean wow it's so
original
not like at
that
it's like a man bro yeah I mean that's
kind of funny though I don't care that I
look like Marilyn Manson no eyebrows bad
it's like an imaginal eyebrows bad you
guys realize this is not forever I'm
just having fun for like a week or two
like who cares bro the fact that you're
willing the fact that you're actually
willing to do something like that is
pretty cool like don't have a Vibe the
only thing this guy would dare to do is
this guy's so stuck bro this guy got no
Vibes I'll tell you that
it's got negative vibes
um yeah he's a he's this talentless hack
that is on critical's uh podcast because
they're friends and I'm like dude you
should not be spending time on Discord
you'd be sucking his dick off and
licking his [ __ ] every waking minute
for the career he gave you you know
milk and milk that prostate brother
reach around bro give that man
a full-on reach or that and pleasure
having sex with them I feel like the
more guys that call me ugly I get like
more powerful I just like suck that in
it's true and I'll just come up with a
better look next week just for you
you're like a you remember the villain
from Fifth Element the more you attack
it the stronger it becomes that's you
yeah so he follows the Playbook which is
just incredible
and the basic big [ __ ] version of a guy
Playbook true he called me fat he called
you ugly and I really think this needs
to be studied as a psychological
phenomenon it doesn't get more basic
than that no and they don't know about
each other that's what's so interesting
it's like you got to think deep and hard
about what this says when you become a
guy who calls me fat and my wife
ugly it's it's
really such a deep-seated that's like a
cry for help from your brain it's uh
Brandon's name bro we need some more
engagement we need oxygen
yeah
flat brain no but it's like the it's so
insecure it's so sad it's just so
[ __ ] crazy dude so there he is um
Haya came out for for us and uh I
thought that was interesting brah
uh
mudahar commented on it debatable if
it's interesting
or is this just a comment
wait what is what did you plank just my
tweets
this says you're just emphasizing
munahar said that the tweets were not a
joke but more like a defamatory
statement and so then here's a link to
the tweets to examine it yeah he's just
saying that based on what Kaya said uh
but what Ian did find uh down below that
is interesting
yeah if you go to mudahar's uh Twitter
account
[ __ ] hell bro this looks like
defamation to me he's got he's got he's
joking about the same [ __ ] what's the
problem that's what that's what I don't
get they're so eager to hate me yes like
you the first thing out of your mouth is
La slime this is before I ever even
talked about him like do you have to be
so [ __ ] edgy that you just have to
hate me like a lemming like Daddy Tate
and all your [ __ ] little home you
know what I mean who said oh
I like he's nice he's thoughtful I just
thought it was a little funny that he
accused me of defamation after
everything we've been through where
because he was just listening to Kaya
you didn't know I thought
in the comments exactly yeah Kai in the
conversation said
Ethan said
um
and [ __ ] kids and all this stuff just
watch it's really short I just want to
bring up another so here is him talking
about my Twitter band I'm actually
curious to get your raw take on this
because you haven't seen it got I got um
bands was
Ethan Klein yeah he got two points
something million followers again he
went on his account and basically
tweeted hi I'm Elon and I'm a pedophile
I love Jeffrey Epstein and his uh little
babies that I used to [ __ ] or whatever
he got banned two things they're both
Hypocrites Elon Musk should be able to
take a joke he's being a big baby but
also you're a hypocrite isn't this what
you said should happen when somebody
improves I don't want to be like an Elon
dick you want to analyze that right
yeah it's all wrong hypocrite
like way to take it so seriously but
when did I say that Elon is [ __ ] kids
you're a [ __ ] hit what was your thing
whatever who cares we talked we talked
us to death already but
yeah so I just wanted to cover him uh
trying to come back instead of just
apologizing uh and being a you know
I want to say real man but again I don't
even know what the [ __ ] that means
oh yeah Charlie talked about it so this
is what I was kind of curious to see
like okay you had this guy on your
podcast straight up [ __ ] lying about
me
and
[Music]
um
talking mad [ __ ] it gets called out and
by the way everyone's like yo I hate
this dude by the way he's the worst part
of the podcast is the whole reason I
don't watch it he's always full of [ __ ]
and everything he says
uh I'm curious what what uh his take was
on all this
the H3 drummer whoa
that's that's how the video started
I I get annoyed a lot of small things
it's like I think I have and I cannot
watch him because he burps constantly
like throughout his streams it's so
weird that's not a weird thing that's
really vulgar I don't like burps yeah I
don't I don't think that's a weird thing
at all well it's like he always hits so
monstrous he might have an issue
honestly so I'm not gonna like point it
out but it does annoy me very much I
mean you could try a little bit to just
like tone it down yeah exactly well okay
whatever I don't I don't we have in fact
some people think it's funny we have
some habits on this show that me I
suppose yeah what and now the belching
but like welcoming okay
you know summer people I don't mean to
like point it out super much just
personally true it just surprised me I
just stop laughing
okay it's Charlie I'm sorry I'm sorry
I'll be more respectful I'm sorry you're
right you're right you're right
keep bringing up oh he has gerd oh he's
my brother well there you go you're my
brother bro girl gang we gotta dab up
I have a guard too
you do you take medicine for it I I I I
I get this like when it Springs up for
like a week or two and then I take
medicine and then it kind of chills out
a little bit
so I'm taking my brothers come on dude
okay I gotta show you this somebody in
the chat just let us know that I guess
he just started his own podcast and it
might be a table oh it'd be a nice sound
this might be one of the worst names for
a podcast you could possibly come up
with oh he made his own podcast
podo files oh my God and then it's
called The Boys auto files
oh I also heard people saying that he
always is talking on the show about
pedophiles like he's obsessed like
always always talking about pedophiles
red flag right can you corroborate that
uh check the hard drive
oh no I cannot oh geez I'm sure
everyone's gonna be hitting subscribe on
potophile yes that's what I want turning
up in my uh just I mean that was my
initial reaction to seeing that was like
wow that's a [ __ ] terrible name and
this this is on their subreddit the top
comment that's got to be the dumbest
name for a podcast it just sounds like
too bad I was talking when I I mean
listen this man is between breathing
sucking off crit and rubbing those two
brain cells together I'm surprised that
he was even able to conceive anything
but just imagine you had a conversation
with another person and decided this is
the name
somebody said is that the name of the
episode of the Pod the pod
it's not just one episode it's cover art
That's The Branding wow no that's the
yeah he's a smart guy I've been trying
to say that from the beginning L.A slime
Ethan Klein says podophile is a bad name
dude you're dumb as hell bro I hope you
watch this and really take that to heart
like I want you to really internalize
what I'm telling you
um just I wouldn't even try to make the
new podcast I just focus on sucking
criticals [ __ ] because
you really gotta hold on to the one
thing you've got going there
and and I don't I don't know I don't
have any techniques to offer you but on
you could probably Google how to give a
good ad
if you need tips there's a lot of videos
there's lots of videos and I believe it
even on YouTube you can find like safer
work tutorials right
I'm assuming they have tutorials for
everything
yeah you probably will so
uh he got mad at Kaya for something Kaya
said on the podcast about the Twitter
stuff
I haven't watched the whole thing on it
so I'm not entirely sure on what it was
about
because like I said I don't even
remember dude we need to dab up over the
guard
I didn't know he had this issue we need
to be homies about this crit we got so
much in common we're dogs man
saying anything like bad about the
Twitter stuff other than it shouldn't
have been surprised to be banned it
wasn't I mean and that's just a little
bit silly and again peace and love no
hate to create we love yeah no peace and
love but it wasn't I mean he kicked this
off with saying he didn't see the
segment and so he didn't see I mean we
we showed the receipts of our private
conversation as it was happening where
you were like I'm totally cool with
getting banned so oh yeah he doesn't
have that info but it's like well I'm
assuming all the chat was saying some
[ __ ] about uh
Kaya [ __ ] up or whatever
and uh well I hope he does look at it as
it is on a show but what's he gonna do
about it's fine he didn't say anything
if anything he said he was he was good
he was on my side which apparently he
wasn't surprised to be banned so I don't
really know where the issue was or maybe
just don't remember what all Kai said
there I just remember it was a short
section where we talked about that yeah
but Chris good he's cool during the
during the section when Kyle was like
why was he surprised and Chris like I
don't think he was surprised a good man
so we love crib for that King burping
King dude burp into my mouth bro I'm all
burnt back in years
burp into your butt brother I'll do
whatever kind of weird [ __ ] you're into
[Applause]
so I don't really know
kind of right to be mad completely
misrepresented what Ethan said
I don't remember him doing that didn't
he just like talk about the Tweet which
the Tweet was hey I'm Elon Musk here's a
picture and it was a picture of Elon
with just Lane Maxwell
actually I didn't even tweet a picture
that's your homie mudahar with the
[ __ ] header of Herman just Lane I
mean like just look at the Tweet you
know
the tweet's funny
the tweet's great but me it was very
funny it was going girl yeah it was good
that we built it together viral yeah he
he recognizes the comedy oh he does yeah
he says it was a banger tweet okay see
he's a he's a [ __ ] God
so the implication is Elon Musk is a
pedophile that's like exactly what the
Tweet was uh literally exactly not what
the Tweet was for the record I said he
was friends with Jeffrey Epstein
I mean you can I mean Bill Gates was
friends with Jeffrey Epstein and I'm
sure he didn't do anything wrong
oh yeah I'm sure about that too
Jeffrey Epstein had friends who didn't
[ __ ] kids you know a couple of them the
hundreds
you telling me prince Andrew [ __ ] [ __ ]
human trafficked people prince Andrew
prince Andrew of the royal family the
Royal British family you wouldn't do
that they would never do anything on
tour Bill Clinton you're saying Bill
Clinton was there Donald Trump
these people are all innocent
your guy was wrong what was the tweet I
don't even remember what he said I'm
asking what the Tweet was that was
absolutely the Ethan tweet though
because I saw it no it wasn't that tweet
went hard
it did go hard though
by the way that blowhorn is not
sanctioned by me
I'm just I just want to put that out
there and I'm not blowing yeah I'm just
playing around me and Charlie were boys
yeah I said hello he said hi who's where
when yeah a crater Clash yeah I said hi
did he know who you were uh yeah
wow to uh the after party oh yeah I
didn't go though because I just was
happy I survived I said pizza at the
hotel what kind of pizza do you have uh
I think it's just cheese just cheese I
like that simple guy keep it classic
yeah yeah
I wish Kurt would come on the podcast I
did his podcast a while ago I'll talk to
him yeah
that'd be great I'd love to talk to him
talk about gerd together oh even though
Jeffrey Epstein committed committed
horrible crimes I do still miss him on
nights like this for the warmth and
camaraderie rest in peace old friend
so the implication is he's a pedophile
I mean
okay who cares right ultimately like who
gives a [ __ ] it's a joke who cares but
that's not what he said
no he come on it's not the same
let's say it's not let's say sure maybe
we can uh quibble about you know what
the implication is or not is it
defamation and is it identity theft
because that is what it is no and also
neither of those things the recap was
insane he goes he said I [ __ ] kids I
love Jeffrey Epstein and I it's like his
summary wasn't was silly as [ __ ]
hahaha
I'm glad Charlie read it though [ __ ]
what
I I it it it's right here this is not an
Ethan tweet you should go back and watch
what he said uh with peace and love
no that's Elon Musk bro what are you
talking about it's right there in the
name
there's no way to know the difference
yeah I mean there's a he's right that
there's there's obviously a subtext
there of like you know but I mean it's
not based on nothing Elon Musk did have
meetings with Jeffrey Epstein he went to
his house like years after he went to
jail
for sex traffic but like you're talking
about like a well it's also all in the
context of what was going on with
Twitter and there's a sub context of the
Twitter Insanity that was going on
exactly there's so much you
applied from this and but
listen he's comparing like a
well-crafted joke to me just tweeting hi
I'm Elon Musk and I [ __ ] kids this is
not what I did yeah he's like
intentionally trying to make it sound
worse like this is if someone read this
they'd be like oh this is a parody this
is a joke yeah like Elon Musk would
never tweet out I miss Jeffrey I've seen
my good friend yeah presumably right
it's funny
it's ironic obviously it's a joke like
that is the joke
and it got banned for it which even
Ethan expected yes thank you for saying
that I I don't I don't know why you're
saying it's a misrepresentation that
that was the tweet
so what are you say it's a
misrepresentation that was the Tweet you
gotta go see what he said and the Tweet
went hard it had like 80k likes
actually it had like 200 000 when I got
banned just for the record I just want
to say that for the record it was
popping off a lot of people are saying
it's misrepresentation
like I said I remember everything that I
said but I remember him saying like that
was the Tweet about the Epstein stuff I
thought of the picture of the slain
Maxwell that might have been a different
Elon Musk impersonator
that was mutahar who was on your show
that was his Banner same thing
calling Elon a pedophile as Elon
basically
but she was a banger but it got him
banned that he expected everyone
expected
I don't know also what's funny I'm glad
he at least understands that yeah yeah
but what's funny is he says I don't know
what he did wrong but he was actually
saying that I was shocked that I got
banned or something like right
everything he was saying was just
[ __ ] dumb and the problem is nobody
challenged him at the time so everybody
watching just takes it as gospel oh yeah
that's what happened
wait me Canyon animated my tweet oh he's
talking about his yeah we should watch
the meat Canyon video did you see it so
good oh I did it so many people were
saying it was a misrepresentation in the
chat like that like I'm looking at the
Tweet here I'll pull it up no you gotta
see it it's right here in the article
you're looking on the wrong side of
things so I don't know why I keep saying
that it was a misrepresentation like I
saw the Tweet too that was 100 the joke
you gotta you can they're trying they're
trying I I don't think it's a bad joke
to make I mean it got a lot of
Engagement it makes fun of Elon I guess
in a goofy way
I and I think the point was he shouldn't
have been surprised to be banned which I
wasn't you can make all the jokes you
want but this isn't surprising he got
banned for it
he deleted the Tweet so now you're
moving the goal post you're saying I
misrepresented the tweet and now you're
saying he deleted it I didn't delete the
tweet no I think they're talking about
Kaya it's so they're just confusion yeah
so much confusion so wait you you had a
theory love that he's you think he knows
about the tweet and he's just I put it
out there that it was a possibility that
he knew what Kaya tweeted but I mean who
at this point who knows probably not
probably I'm curious it's fine you know
he seems genuinely confused at this
point change anything like I didn't
misrepresent it
but yeah I don't really understand the
whole situation clear that I really get
what it was all about but anyway I I
listened Charlie's Fair he's a king he's
a God bro and I want to gird into his
[ __ ] butthole dude you know what I'm
saying Hell yeah because we're dogs like
that I want to blast one of those
[ __ ] gerd farts right into his ass
blast him off like a rocket well I
didn't even plan to come be on the show
I just heard you say somebody was
talking [ __ ] about me I have to come see
yeah he was who joined the Gang
yeah damn you look good what the [ __ ]
what the [ __ ]
showing some vintage LV
it's my boy uh from Instagram
uh gray
matte gray or something what did he do
with it it's funny no he makes funny
Graphics it says very lazy oh yeah he
gets sued for that for sure he was if he
was mass producing it I thought that was
actually a Louis Vuitton shirt funny
foreign
Kendall said Ethan's next costume should
be Slimer from Ghostbusters that's so
good idea
that would be fire how would you even
have fun thank you a round of applause
for you everyone she's the best isn't
she folks hero
taking eyebrows to the next level Flex
them let's see some eyebrows up eyebrows
down let's see the wave all right I
can't do the wave you can do it right
not not that good guys so beautiful
uh thank you what a treat what a
treasure what a pleasure what a what a
pleasure and we love Charlie don't we
love Charlie hate Haya
um like like everybody
kind of like everybody apparently who
watches that podcast
so it turns out I'm a huge fan just like
everyone else
um
yeah that's pretty funny I thought that
was good
you know that's pretty good I guess the
fat man bad that you look ugly
it's pretty good I guess and then oh
there was another little c-man update
actually okay great we sent him the um
this is a good one we sent him the uh
photo of Jay Leno in the hyperbolic
chamberic hyperbolic Time Chamber where
he's training for his for the Cell Games
yeah and uh and asked him what he
thought and we reported the other day
that he did reply and he thought they
were great so I replied to him said
that's Jay Leno uh thanks so much we
were just talking about on the show we
wanted your opinion and you replied
okay
wow no punctuate just okay hey I
appreciate the response not everybody
gets back to you
you know
not everybody would get back to you and
so right people have been asking all
[ __ ] episodes so just real quick
3200 to DPI there it is
thank you it's so good
one more time give me him with that DPA
1 600 DPI if anyone knows who this guy
is please we need to contact them
there's so much we could do with them
1375 epi
turn this [ __ ] all the way up Dan come
on yeah crank we got to hear them 1200
DPI
and then let's bring it back down let's
bring it back down give me 800 DPI oh
yeah that's the good one I like when
he's done it's smooth yeah
800 DBI
800.
maybe I am he's best when he's calmed
down a little bit people say he's so hot
he's so [ __ ] hot so [ __ ] I love that
DPI guy
somebody I hope somebody on the
subreddit makes some uh DPI guy fan art
yeah like a sexy Mouse I like dreams
that's what I'm saying we have this big
fantasy we need to make him basically
like a V tuber yeah he needs to start
publishing music oh yeah
yeah I raised my DPI every day
I like the cruise at 800 DPI
um lots of love for the for the members
only live stream Beto said
that uh the recent discourse was we need
to talk about doing a true crime
documentary and on Tuesday what happened
was
yo Bros check out this sick [ __ ] it's
crazy disappears for 10 minutes to poop
yeah it's good it was good there's lots
of Love Actually I saw a really funny
post on the subreddit about it let me
try to pull this up
the guy who was squinting at the screen
yeah I can find that it's so funny I
love it
yeah more fan love for the members only
live stream
I can't find it you'll have to pull it
up yeah I'm fine please have
Joba from Brock Hampton on the Pod they
just broke up and Joba followed you on
Twitter well we have no way to reach him
I'm not on Twitter lazy wait followed me
I don't have an account I don't know
dude
oh I'm gonna run a muck on Elon Musk I'm
put parody in the title and I am going
to just
anymore
nothing but muskweeds no I'm going to be
a dedicated Elon Musk yeah that's great
which was my original
um
plan going into it
I like the crew that 800 DPI on Sunday I
go up to 1200. on Monday I'd like to
cruise at 500 DPI 1600 DPI I take it
easy at 500 DPI hmm
I like the crew at 900 DPI
here's the post thank you for this yeah
more fan love for the members only live
stream
uh I'm really enjoying these memories
only live stream he said and
as you can see
we get the best content only
uh I know it's funny we were actually
having lots of fun on the members only
but uh yeah lots of fun there
yeah
good times huh
love that
that guy looked Alpha by the way I don't
know what he's doing watching this show
he looked out for right beard
yeah maybe he came over from tick tock
oh what's up y'all any tater tots
y'all know what's funny y'all saying I
top G but no one has told me what he's
what what has top G ever done wrong well
he has an open okay let's not bro shut
up shut the [ __ ] up
uh Gabriella I've been a fan since
Israel days married the man who
introduced me to you and we just
celebrated eight years together lovely
lovely lovely that's nice congrats
congratulations I'd love to hear it
this podcast brings people together what
can I say you know so true
all right speaking of bringing people
together let's talk about Tim Poole and
Tucker Carlson who are advocating for um
LGBT LGBT
LG LGBT no there's no P let's get the P
out of there quick
LGB well if it's up to Tim pull there
would be a p in there there's no right
lgbtq well plus yeah
plus choose a word that you want to
identify with symbol but yes so this is
really concerning like the discourse
where it's gone on trans issues and gay
issues and stuff like
um
it's it's it's honestly disturbing it's
it's gotten to the point where it's
it's just downright
concerning and scary Tim Poole who's uh
the uh
you guys know Temple everyone should
have nukes okay all of it
thank you uh last Saturday a gunman
tragically
murdered five people and left 17 injured
at Club Q in Colorado Springs so sorry p
is I'm so sorry keep going what happened
P is for pansexual we blank oh we love
playing our pans so it is
cooked me in a pan and smother me and
goob Daddy
pansexual
that means they'll take goofy right
they're into all goose every type of
group I mean every types of Goo we
welcome all Goose
that's technically what it means right
they're attracted to everybody it's a
dad joke pansexual fry me up
put me in a pan and ride me up with goo
daddy why that's good I'm just being
real about the noise
it's funny it's just
it's such a dad joke all right well
you are a dad I'm a dad and also my
professional comedian Dan so yeah you
are obligated to laugh Country and
contractually
I felt worthless
goo is as goo does someone said and I
couldn't agree more goo Pride ah yes
AV is picking up all the moves back
there slowly learning
hit me with the whole Fouseytube
sequence
do you know how to do it I felt ugly I
felt gay I felt that no like
a tastes like beef jerky sure does man
that was fast
hey fousey what are you thinking um
hey Phil see what does penis taste like
it tastes like beef jerky right that
makes sense it's CR it's chewy in the
same way it's kind of immediately it's
kind of meaty in the same way
and he is gay
you don't have to be gay to suck dick I
felt gay
you can feel gay when you suck dick I
mean that makes sense if you're a guy
I'm not gay no more it's a gay act but
I'm more than gay I'm
what was that I haven't heard that one
I don't know just this keep starting
more in the game
Zach was saving that one foreign
that's super old but yeah maybe he was
waiting for the right moment hit me with
that again I'm more than gay I'm I'm
already gay
[Music]
so anyway here's Tim Poole
um
Temple
what's what really disturbs me is he
really fancies himself as kind of like a
moderate I mean he's obviously super
reactionary this is the guy who
predicted a 50 state 49 maybe 50 state
Landslide for Donald Trump he's a giant
[ __ ] tool he's one of these grifters
that pretends he's like a
a liberal
over this past week we saw he really is
such a piece of [ __ ] man absolutely
but anyway what he said
their bodies have not been laid to rest
and Tim pool and his elk
are already calling the slain victims
groomers and pedophiles because it took
place at a drag show
now trigger warning this will upset the
[ __ ] out of you it is just
um barbaric it's gruesome
it's inhuman I mean I don't know what to
say it's like this callousness this is
actual absolute
you're you're blaming people who just
were murdered by a raging homophobic
freak
so here's Temple he says uh
he quoted this guy Kurt he said I don't
think we have to tolerate pedophiles
because some [ __ ] shot up a gay bar
I mean that's insane take right like
already we shouldn't tolerate pedophiles
grooming Kids Club Q had a grooming
event
how do we prevent the violence and stop
The Grooming
now Club Q correct me if I'm wrong it
had an all-age drag event I don't what
is Club Q I don't have all the
background here I just saw the post here
I'll keep going through these and we'll
The Grooming of children is not stopping
people are calling for more violence I
do not think legislators will stop the
grooming you mean make it illegal for
kids to go
to a family event is that what you mean
uh yeah this is America I thought you
were down with freedom isn't he like a
Libertarian who believes in like freedom
for everyone for everything
I think that kids should not be able to
go to family events
people will not stop calling for
violence so you tell me what happens
next
then he posts this post from Club Q
Colorado Springs
it's a two-parter he shows first
uh here they're announcing two days ago
let's prep for a fantastic Sunday fun
day
doors open
at 11AM for our all ages Drag Brunch
join us for a fantastic drink special
and even more amazing drag show then
stick around for an All-Star cast of our
freshest faces we're celebrating
transgender day of remembrance with a
variety of gender identities and
performance style show starts at 8pm
and then so that's apparently he goes
here's what they did and here's the
obvious results of that post which is
Club Q is devastated by the census
attack on our community our prayers and
thoughts are with all victims and their
families and friends we thank the quick
reaction of heroic customers that
subdued the gunman and ended this hate
attack so he's saying that they had it
coming I mean and and he's literally
saying that they [ __ ] brought this on
themselves by having a family event
where where men dress as women right
that's drag yeah that's drag
argument
saying that right now
first of all is just like
people just died people were just
murdered dude it's not time for you to
talk about this it's so callous it's so
[ __ ] disgusting it's not like look
you can talk that that reminds me of
like oh we're not going to talk about
gun control so I'm not going to say you
know you have to wait to talk about
something but it's the way he's blaming
the victims yeah it's just it's [ __ ]
nuts dude it's it's inhuman yeah it's
unfathomably callouses the argument
isn't strong enough to have
this strong of a stance I feel like
after something like that happened like
gun control that's a real like we need
it there's no statistics proving there's
nothing like to speak in absolutes that
all drag is not for children is
like the fundamental offensiveness that
you find in is that there's a man
standing there in a dress then I don't
understand the whole thing I'm gonna get
into that let me read his tweets because
I actually want to break this down I
really don't understand it
um
he says it seems that around 10 pm Club
Q posted they were having an all-ages
drag show
two hours later the shooter came in
people keep calling for wood chippers
and this is what happens
and Stephen Crowder quote tweeted of
course and said strong legislation to
protect children and armed populates to
protect themselves and their kids again
he's saying if I saw my kid at a drag
show I would go kill everyone there I
don't know
um also what the this this fantasy of
legislators protecting kids like are you
[ __ ] serious what is that legislation
actually going to say kids aren't
allowed near gay people like honestly
think through that what are you saying
are you even presenting an actual idea
here
okay so Tim Poole says that
um Club Q had a grooming event
Okay so
and they're pedophiles their pedophiles
grooming kids that's what happened at
Club Q
so
um what is Club Q like
it's
I I don't have any I want to understand
this totally to to properly
break this down okay I'll look more I'm
looking into it now I just want to be
sure on everything it's just
it's God damn I'm having like heartburn
do we have in the um yeah we do Tums or
some [ __ ]
yes we do it's been saving my life today
God damn it I don't know why it's
happening you should oh I know why I had
Mexican leftovers this morning
um do you want to look at the Yelp page
for it sure yeah I want to learn as much
as I can about it
all right thank you
while we're Gathering stuff thank you
Shredder kill him
oh man
I like these
all right let's learn about this
grooming slash pedophile Event club Cube
Club Q is
let's go to the website
yeah I'm leaving you up I know
oh it's just it's all in remembrance now
obviously considering what happened
um
I don't see anything about the the
business here maybe
oh I didn't send that um here it is it's
just it's a it's a bar it looks like a
bar a gay bar
right
yeah and so
a gay bar opens its
doors on the weekend
this is I guess an uh it says it's a
fun-loving place
with frequent drag shows and playful
menu items such as gaoli fries
franchise topped with garlic aioli and
death by Rainbow Flight a group of six
candy flavored shots
nobody parties like Club Q says the
club's Facebook page
the club had hosted a punk themed drag
show earlier that night
by a performer named delusional then a
DJ began playing a promotional flyer for
the club promised dancing till 2 A.M the
cover was seven dollars
it's a gay bar and they have drag shows
so if we go again to this this is the
post that apparently
oh what's up Teddy
oh I I think you misheard me buddy
you okay
thought uh Ethan called his name yeah so
what was going on in the background here
flyer for the okay perfect I mean I just
really want to know because if you're
going to accuse someone who was just
murdered of being a pedophile and a
groomer you better be like Yeah a
hundred percent certain right
so let's get all of our facts here and
analyze this so here this is the flyer
all ages musical Drag Brunch
show starts at noon
okay
is this it
yeah that was the flyer on there social
media
okay
so looks like
not much to go off of and then this is
the post that he showed as evidence that
they deserved it
so they said once again
let's prep for a fantastic Sunday fun
day 11 A.M noon all ages Drag Brunch
then stick around for All-Stars cast of
Fresh's faces we're celebrating
transgender day of remembrance you gotta
love that irony
and so
from what I can tell as they open up the
bar
and to have like a fun I don't think it
doesn't seem like sexual or
I don't think there's they're not gonna
be nudity or anything it seems like
people just in drag which is when dudes
dress as women right also just to note
they raise funds with these direct shows
Bingo Knights and other events they give
it to organizations that provide safe
spaces for the lgbtq plus community so
it's a charitable event too to put to uh
that's great I mean it's activism right
so
now I I cannot understand to an extent
like I I don't know I I can't really I'm
it's like they having an event where men
dress as women now I don't know if you
know this but even in [ __ ]
Shakespearean times that's what they did
in play
because women weren't allowed on stage
and those [ __ ] dressed and they
looked yes they used prepubes in boys
oh that's [ __ ] up that's even weirder
bruh so I'm saying like are y'all really
gonna say that
dudes dressing up as women is how are
you gonna say that's pedophilia and
grooming I just don't understand the the
leap there like what is this based on
more than just this fire and
announcement because that's like an
insanely I mean it's it's working on
this is this is something that they've
this is a project of theirs that they've
been working on for
I don't know the last couple years I
forget when all this groomer talk
started but yeah I mean it obviously
though in this country culturally we
have a long ways to go
people's acceptance
uh has gone way up in the last decade
and we are starting to see a violent
backlash to that not that there wasn't
always that an undercurrent of that but
it's becoming explicit at this point
correct someone said did it say
bottomless driver dancers on fire it
said bottomless mimosa
I see not [ __ ] nude people yeah but
um
but yeah I mean they're really cranking
up to 11 uh what has always been there
and
somebody said it started with trans
bathrooms uh yeah yeah exactly and yeah
there is a conscious effort to sort of
equate any sort of non-conforming
uh sexual identity with pedophilia
um
and why are they calling these people
pedophiles It's like because they're
prejudiced but it's like dude what the
[ __ ] are you talking about
you can't just do that I mean this this
is actually boarding on I'll be honest
like Alex Jones level of defamation on
people they just died
he's saying we can't tolerate pedophiles
and groomers I mean this is actually I
feel like actionable defamation on
people who were just murdered
I I genuinely do you can't just [ __ ]
say their pedophiles and groomers
and that the violence is justifiable
that I think that's actionable
defamation based on what just happened
Alex Jones I really do
you can't just [ __ ] say that [ __ ]
dude
okay
like
and somebody said uh donate five dollars
and said saw my first drag queens in Key
West at 11. I didn't even know they were
men until my dad said something it's not
sexual it's just expression dude it's
like they're just like having fun
they're like huge personalities they're
fun they're over the top they're
colorful
also like every artist like a parade
some shows are explicit some aren't like
there's obviously a wide spectrum of
what types of shows there are and this
was an all ages brunch
which probably which means that it's
going to be a problem ages what's going
to be in the content because it was for
children
if you
I'm just I'm even four children I mean
when I hear all ages when I hear a punk
themed all-day show I think they just
mean like you can bring your teenager I
mean it means under 21. I mean you don't
have to be exactly that's my impression
like that's my understanding of oh yeah
they're probably targeting like older
teenagers anyway it's not like bring
your son it's a bar so obviously yeah
that's correct me if I'm wrong but
that's where my mind
a punked themed drag show is that's
going to be teenagers and up I would be
surprised if there was a bunch of like
five and under kids there you know I
mean but but again I don't even think
that there is it's like who cares like
it's not inherently
at all uh Ron DeSantis said that a new
law preventing Florida schools from
teaching kids about lgbtq plus people
should be called the anti-grooming bill
that's [ __ ] insane bro do you but do
you know what's funny about like this
whole grooming thing
is if you want to know what grooming
actually is look up the story about pet
the pedophiles and child molesters in
the church there's huge bombshell story
broke about the Catholic church in uh in
like New England area that we covered on
the show a few years ago there was this
a whole underground organization of of
molesting priests and they would put a
necklace on the kids the choir boys the
the uh the the the the who were like
open and groomed and prepared to be
molested they would actually mark them
so their friends knew that they could
molest them too that's grooming and it's
actually happening in places like the
[ __ ] Church in fact it's it's it's
all been studied it's all open it's all
done it's printed it's been investigated
that's grooming why are you calling gay
people groomers
it's in the [ __ ] church that you guys
apparently love so well
it's hey come on can you find that
excerpt for me I want to I want these
people to understand what grooming is
that's happening in their backyard it's
happening in their Sunday Schools
they're not watching this and they're
also not they don't care I mean
[ __ ] isn't Matt Walsh who's like the
one who's leading the charge on this
super religion isn't he Catholic yeah
not not just religious but I believe
he's Catholic like a hardcore one Matt
Walsh Catholic
but yeah yeah he's hardcore religious
I'm just saying like y'all really
[ __ ] occult that that's that's so
disturbing Ron DeSantis calls ban on
teaching kids lgbtq plus when I search
Matt Walsh Catholic
an IMDb page of I guess a no he's not I
don't know why there's an IMDb page for
one of the uh Maga guy in a car race
that's on the that's on the covers this
dude's sitting in his car talking to a
GoPro always the thing is the Oakleys I
guess he he needs oh yeah he did defend
the church who's calling gay people
groomers defended the church he said
these people who are quote unquote
molested are old enough to defend
themselves yeah and the problem isn't
with pedophiles it's with gay people in
the church yeah
yeah that's good stuff you can pull that
clip actually too he says that
yeah Ron DeSantis says if you're against
it she tweeted you're probably a groomer
at least you don't denounce The Grooming
of four to eight-year-old children
average four to eight though just that
little range
the average number of tweets each day
using slurs such as groomer and
pedophile in relations at LBGTQ plus
people increased by 406 percent in the
month after the Florida bill was passed
these people really just want gay people
to die I I don't know what to say I mean
that's been the sort of implication for
a long time and I think that is what is
so
uh disturbing about this particular
instance and we're far from the only
people to point this out is that the
pretense of like any sort of sympathy uh
is just gone now and it's just they just
want him to die yeah like it's like
they're basically just saying like yo
yeah so you had a drag cake drag uh
event for all ages well like yeah then
you had of course you guys got of course
y'all got murdered yeah
and he goes well shootings is bad but so
are grooming events so we need to focus
on stopping those so that the shooters
shooters don't have anywhere to go
hey guys you want to know what um actual
grooming looks like priests used gold
crosses to ID kids as abuse targets
from the Pennsylvania report
let me read that a [ __ ] again so you
all can hear in the back what the [ __ ]
grooming is
priests use gold crosses to ID kids as
abuse targets
Decades of abuse by children by 301
priests
and y'all worried about drag events
bro stop
girl
that's one of the most disturbing things
I've ever read by the way that they were
marking kids for abuse
that's [ __ ] up that is really really
really disturbing man so I actually saw
something right before the show
um
that is
very upsetting so uh let me read this as
you look that up
um he told me they the priests would
give their boys their Altar Boys or
their favorite boys these crosses George
testified so he gave me a bat a big gold
cross to wear
in the report the grand jury said the
crosses were designations that these
children were victims of sexual abuse
they were a signal to other predators
that the children had been desensitized
to sexual abuse and they were optimal
targets for further victimization
you want to talk about grooming
you really want to [ __ ] talk about
killing people who who played dress-up
actually these people play dress up too
I mean come on that's how you even not
gonna like I can't get past this [ __ ]
and you're talking about grooming events
here's the oh this is the shooter's dad
color and this guy looks put together
the Colorado shooter's Dad I'm finding
out his son murder people they started
telling me about the incident a shooting
and then I go on to find out it's a gay
bar I got scared [ __ ] is he gay bruh
and he's not gay so I said feel I'm a
Conservative Republican oh I'm so
relieved he's not gay he was just there
to kill people not actually the kids to
do it thank God
now that's [ __ ] gold baby
that's gold
that is good should we be uh follow-up
tweet too
let me watch this video first for the
shooting involving you know there are
multiple people right and then I go on
they were on one fine it's a gay bar
yeah right and and I was like oh my God
it's a gay as a scare us oh my God and
he's not gay so thank you
that's it hey man well you guys have had
are you [ __ ] for real bro
yeah
they have a Mormon this guy's on drugs
or something by the way yeah he seems
like a meth head he seems like he'd
raise a [ __ ] nutty that would go
shoot up a club
I mean clearly a failure on all levels
here I like how these these like broke
oh I called that look look at what cam
just said
oh that's him
apparently he was on the show
intervention uh for me oh my God so meth
he was on the show intervention
good timing on there I love how he's
worried about gay people yo after
injecting meth Aaron masturbates for up
to 10 to 12 hours
sounds like a method
is that what you're doing meth you just
jerk off for 12 hours well not everybody
but yeah I don't know that's the thing
sounds like a good time
I'm gonna tear the skin off my [ __ ]
brother yeah I mean that's it I'm gonna
beat that [ __ ] to look like a hot dog
brother
[Laughter]
gives canned food poisoning oh [ __ ] put
some mustard on come on
too soon those are rookie numbers bro
for sure bro if I was on meth I'd be
jerking off for at least 20 hours you
[ __ ]
20 hours straight you do anything else
during that time like you multitask you
watch like anime and jerk up or you just
dedicated you're probably you probably
do multitask I don't imagine I mean I
can't imagine that staying interest for
12 hours straight so on the phone with
your mom yeah
holy [ __ ] dude
oh that's great yes so um I look at
these conservatives right like he's
[ __ ] there's no social uh safety nets
for him
and
he's a meth head and he's worried about
his son
being gay he probably hates Democrats
okay check out the follow-up tweet in
that thread
you know it's like the conservatives
have brainwashed these people it's like
dude you have nothing
there's nobody in this country there's
no system of support for you who you
deserve it and maybe your son would end
up being a mass murderer like the system
has failed y'all and you somehow are mad
at the people that actually want to help
you it's crazy
Republican
and we don't do gay okay yeah I can't
get an answer we don't do gay we do math
sugar water around here we only do math
okay I'm a God-fearing man I Fear God
and being sober
imagine yeah
said he sounds like the Men in Black
alien though yeah
you've got to say mannerisms
I need sugar
what's sugar mean meth more more math
yeah
we don't think I can't get answers from
the attorneys really but they're saying
that somebody's really just it's
involving a gay bar or something I don't
know
um I don't know what the heck you do if
you have a gay bar
um I don't know what to do well he's
accused of going on a mass shooting at a
gay bar and killing 550 Colorados okay
12.
gay
dude how is this real
how the [ __ ] is this real
this isn't real this is a movie this is
like not this man literally said on the
news your son killed five people okay
well at least she's not gay how
I I just read this they put in the court
filings that the kid who murdered all of
those people
um is non-binary and wants to be
referred to it would they them
pronounselves he's trolling and or
trying to get out of crime charges by
being like no I'm non-binary trying to
be cute that's so [ __ ] yeah no it's
that's not real
cool dude well I can see why his son's
[ __ ] up
I don't see I don't know he seems like
he comes from a good solid home good
stock you know what I mean again next
week you a little bit more about it I
don't understand how this is real this
is [ __ ] real
quick
we gotta sound bite that I mean it's
dark but we can make good use of it
yeah
I'm just glad I'm glad he's not gay okay
he killed five people
all right well come on were they gay all
right nice
glad he's not gay
holy [ __ ]
Colorado shooter's dad I praised him for
violent Behavior really early I told him
it works you'll get immediate results
cool dude brother
he went on to praise the shooter's
Grandpa a mega Republican politician
wait what
yep named Randy volpel who supported the
January 6 insurrection
so his dad
or his mom's dad unclear from the way
it's worded it could be his mom's dad
you know what I think we need to get
this guy in Congress
I think he'd be a valuable asset to the
American uh public
[Music]
violent Behavior really early there's
something that works
I praise him for violent Behavior really
early I just don't say that it works
people saying don't sound butt okay all
right
you know what I mean
I praised him for violent Behavior
really early why would you even say this
instant and you'll get whoo What is that
whose is that look who are you bro I
praised him for violent Behavior you're
saying that on the TV I mean he's
tweaked out of his [ __ ] mind but not
not like excusing it but like but he's
speaking the truth who says that
an insane method says that right but
I feel like
by the way here's his Wikipedia page
he's a he's a former porn star uh oh
turn a comment from Tick Tock said
Ethan lost me as a fan when he joined
the Taliban [ __ ] I knew that would turn
some people off sorry about that dude
that was years ago at this point I J I'm
more Isis boy than Taliban he's
denounced the patella ban many times on
this show since signing up what were you
saying who's a gay porn star uh this guy
that no not a gay porn star just a he's
a porn star straight porn star well was
uh I sent you the link look at his
Wikipedia page he's got a little page
all right let me watch this video and
open his Wikipedia page Praise Him for
violent Behavior really early I can't
believe this guy it's instant and you'll
get immediate results
and you'll always a good fight had you
taught him more tolerance let me be
direct
you know these guys he would have been
more tolerant of gay people apparently I
think that my anti-day anti-smetics that
comes from the writing of a conservative
extraordinaire and I've been very vocal
about that it was I support Randy lapel
for his grandpa I love my angel being a
good American healthy president someday
um
how did they even find this guy like
this guy is so [ __ ] messed out
surprised they tracked him down Randy
that's a good man right there that's a
that's the best man for the job it was
okay to be gay you know because it's
cool to be gay
it's not because I think it's not cool
at all I think it's um my opinion about
gays is it is just not okay because
she's standing against homosexuality bro
you literally have sores on your face
from being on meth so long why are you
even having an opinion about anything
I'm sorry but you got strong enough
morality here You've Got No Room for
strong opinions when you look and sound
like that my dude
Jesus Christ so here this is the guy
he's got a Wikipedia page love that
he's like John Cena on [ __ ] math
thank you thanks guys appreciate the
backup on that one
he damn he's got an extensive history
Aaron Franklin Brink also he's his stage
name is Dick Delaware
this man who works in adult industry
MMA fighter it looks like too prior to
that interesting life actually played
Thanos soon enough father of mass
shooter you play Thanos in The Avengers
yeah he looks like Josh Brolin
he looks like dick Delaware to me
he's an american professional mix
martial artist and pornographic actor
he's also competed in King of the cage
has made several mainstream appearances
including being interviewed about his
son murdering people and being cool
really dope Uh Oh no you're right sorry
that I was making that up but he was
actually in a Marvel movie yeah it says
here he portrayed Electro in Spider-Man
XXX a porn parody
swear to God
I thought you weren't that far off
yeah he's pretty much in the MCU he is
the father of Anderson Lee Aldrich the
accused perpetrator of the Club Q
shooting
in an interview after the shooting
Brinks said when he learned the shooting
was at a gay bar he was initially
horrified by the possible that Anderson
might be gay but relieved to find out
that wasn't the case
that's your legacy now what a line on
your Wikipedia page
that's a legacy let's see he went to
prison
shocking actually for marijuana which is
kind of a shame
um bogus
he was released at 24.
he started doing MMA
obviously got punched in the head of
YouTube many times then he started doing
porn as dick Delaware
his first title was called come drippers
four
that's a great one
um
well no not as good as to be fair yeah
exactly I lost interest after three yeah
it's just come on you know I was just
like oh I've seen it drip I've seen it
drip
a million times
uh he's currently competing for the
Gladiator Challenge promotion
who's still a bare knuckle fighter I
think he has seen him in bum farts all
right
winner gets meth
whatever you're chewing on is very loud
it's Tom I'm suffering all right
I'll be down soon
he'll return to the adult industry
apparently
here's his IMDb page somebody said MMA
porn meth but nothing gay sure buddy
yeah that's what dude
100
and by the way it's not easy I've heard
I don't know if it's true but I think it
is is that male performers like entry
level ones
for either getting porn enough [ __ ]
dudes as a male performer it was almost
zero percent
but you just gotta pay your dues and
[ __ ] dudes even if you're not gay huh
like I'm pretty sure that's
but yeah this dude definitely likes dick
and he obviously hates himself he's the
dad from American Beauty
the neighbor died right took me a second
and a lot of fights under his belt
maybe he'll fight Jake Paul next
foreign
you know
let's get that going we said Ethan eats
like a camel I'm naked [ __ ] it I don't
care I'm not even gonna hide I don't
care oh that's a good one I'll take it
yeah so
he shoe nice maybe I should get you nice
vibes from dick Dallas
yeah so Tim Poole here is co-signing
basically with his dad
and I just find it like this is probably
the most despicable thing I've seen him
say it's
yeah I mean it's like you said temple
like I mean we make fun of him a lot and
it's mostly just for him being dumb and
saying stupid [ __ ]
um but all of it yes but he rarely Rises
to the level of like a crowd or Matt
Walsh or like those people it's usually
just more silly like silly dumb silly
dumb rather than like horrifying dumb
but yeah he really uh jumped the shark
here a little bit
jump the shark
you don't know that expression no I do
it was like I mean I don't know that
that goes far enough to describe what
you did yeah I'm understating a little
bit
yeah he really Justified the innocent
killing of bar patrons here yeah exactly
okay nailed it over sure well he really
called for the further violence against
lgbtq plus people has Justified
shark hey you ever been to the church
bro
don't even talk to me about groomers
until you [ __ ]
I was serious when I said disband the
church by the way people got so many
angry at me churches all ages all the
time that's [ __ ] that's grooming that
is and by the way what did they do at
church they bring the kids in they
indoctrinate them they say hey God's
your saver that's [ __ ] up they're kids
bro and then they go all ages right yeah
they're dressed up these men are dressed
the [ __ ] up I think there were towns
they wear gowns
dresses they're doing the grooming right
God let me show you real drag event and
then you all tell me which one is more
terrifying hold on
let me pull this up
you want to see a real drag event
look no further than this [ __ ] brothers
and sisters look at this look at this
grooming event right here oh my God I
know it
that right there is a grooming and
pedophile event
and it's all ages every day
at least at that club it's you know 21
over at night
they're giving alcohol to miners there
too yo that communion
encouraging it yo okay kid take the body
of Christ in your mouth gay
I thought I was gonna be arrested as a
kid
from I'm telling you man look at this
[ __ ] little look at this little look
at this queen slaying
this [ __ ] is dragged up to his
ears
just saying man the irony is crazy oh
yeah you guys like green are you guys in
a green mood there what is it
the Green Day at the drag Club
you know what I mean stop it St
Patrick's Day brunch
all all ages uh bondless mimosas
bottomless Body of Christ
bring me your children
bring your children to our all ages drag
event
where you can drink on the blood of G of
a grown man and also taste his body
come all ages take this Golden Crown
take this Golden Cross Sun
you've You're My Chosen favorite boy
take this Golden Cross somebody said
that the green outfit is a serve
actually
I think it serves I'm not I'm not even
[ __ ] I agree it's good I think I think
it's good for all ages event
all of them the green yeah it's not it's
not I mean
to be real compared to this cadaver why
are you even gonna dude I'm sorry but
this is just disrespectful to put a
cadaver out like this there's no way to
do an open casket showing yeah none of
this drag is my style lay this man to
rest yeah
it's a little too much it's a little too
much Camp it's a little too look at this
[ __ ] nobody's gonna even believe this is
real
look at that Crown okay Queen
tell them you like sucking dick without
telling me you like sucking dick you
know what I mean
you're a dick rider you're a dick
look they even Halloween costumes in
another [ __ ] you know
yo brother check out that Laurel bro
have a good old time with that you know
what I'm saying Pope
[Music]
um
I bet you you and hunger FF could have a
good old time with that boy
all ages by the way oh boy
look at this [ __ ] he got he got
he got his restaurant yeah
holy choreography that's what I see
this is a grooming this is
this is absolutely
uh absurd
is that one still alive that's the one
that retired are you kidding me he's
dust bro he was dust in this photo well
I'm I know
it was like a hundred thousand years old
he's still alive what yeah oh let's see
95. there you go yeah oh my God he's the
one that like God is real he's the one
that mysteriously retired early you know
like the pope is
I think it's more of like a Sidious it's
a dark side is a pathway to many
abilities type thing more than God you
think he's uh doing a a Plagueis yeah
life force transfer yeah yeah contact
sucking the souls [ __ ] the souls out
of the little boy's dicks yeah he was
also uh he was also in the Hitler Youth
yes oh my goodness so can this be the
last one is that what's up well that
that that's the previous Pope right uh
we already have do we know who's next
yeah he's both already well they don't
they don't decide until
um they well usually they don't decide
until one dies but in his case he yeah
oh yes he's the Argentinian guy I think
after this one we call it a day maybe be
the last one well listen I don't want
pedophilia and grooming to continue so
I'm down to stop the whole poop thing
all right we're gonna we're gonna wrap
it up thank you guys have a great
Thanksgiving we'll see you on Friday
hopefully for a special we do have that
planned for Thanksgiving hope so
all right guys
um
see you guys on Friday
[Music]